do you watch a lot of horror films
i try to keep up with them if i can yeah
do you watch more let's say retro or do
you watch more current
in terms of retro uh horror movies i
think i've covered the basics that i
have to cover i don't know if i
passionately consume them the way i
should i try to keep up with the modern
ones that are coming out
because it will be embarrassing not to
but with the old ones i would say maybe
i've seen
under 100 of them 50 of them or
something not like as many as a lot of
my fellow horror filmmakers
watch for sure so is there anything
about the older
films that you get nostalgic about or
missed i mean i was just watching a
bunch of old um
humphrey bogart films and it was just so
wonderful how you could just be focused
on the acting and the dynamics between
the characters i realize that's not
horror
a lot of them were mystery but it feels
like so much of that is taken away these
days
and why do you think oh maybe just focus
on
really cool effects and and having sort
of larger than life sort of experiences
where i kind of miss that like quiet
story but hey
that's just me i don't know that is
probably the case that with the older
movies people had more patience and
there was less
reliance on the spectacle right because
the effects just weren't as advanced
as that so it had to be storytelling and
it had to be acting
and all that that makes sense yeah that
oh that's interesting i like spectacle
yeah that makes you know that makes
sense maybe we should remake some of the
old ones not just the old slasher movies
not just make
friday the 13th for the 50th time but do
some of the quiet old ones see how the
audience would react to that
experiment do you think that so that's a
product of just how
it's a spectacle every time we turn on
the internet you know there's so many
things notifications
i think so with netflix and all the
patience of people i think has
become so much shorter it's like get to
the point i'll give you it used to be 10
minutes i think now it's probably a
minute i see that with myself if i flick
through netflix something amazing better
happens within the first 90 seconds or
there are 2 000 other
you know movies and shows and whatever
on offer and i'll switch to one of them
and i think that's become
more and more extreme through the years
i don't know where that's going to go in
the next 10 years it's going to be
interesting
what do you miss about cinema from from
whether it's 10 years ago i mean you can
definitely see in increments like the
2000s there was definitely
it seemed like a different style versus
1970s 80s i mean what i miss about the
70s
is that there was a real um courage
for devastating endings i think we
talked about that last time during the
interview
that there's such a thrill in watching a
movie and you genuinely don't know
if the protagonists are going to be okay
or not which i think was very much the
case in the 70s you didn't know they
would just
kill a protagonist off in the last
minute and you just sit there devastated
they don't do that so much anymore they
didn't i think they lost that during the
80s
and then in the 90s it was always more
everything had to be kind of wrapped up
kind of neatly
all the way down to seven which i think
had that negative ending
um at some point and then the studio
tested it and said the audience can't
process it so we need some kind of
positive wrap up on the whole thing
i would love if that came back if that
unpredictability and that kind of
danger came back from the 70s let's see
do you think two because now there's the
opportunity for a franchise and so if
you if you kill off that beloved
character then
i think the franchise is one of the
considerations in the in the bigger
movies
but then then franchises have carried on
with different characters but i think
we've also what has happened
is the anthology idea that we've been
much more become much more comfortable
with
um that you can now carry on a franchise
the saw franchise let's say
jigsaw has been dead for five movies or
something and they still kind of make
movies with it and so much name
recognition now
that it's maybe not even that much um
attachment to the protagonist anymore as
it used to be
thinking about it now right because more
marketing because what's being marketed
is the name and the franchise
and not like in the conjuring there's
another whole conjuring universe
which pumps out movie after movie after
movie but it's not even that there's one
protagonist that is pulled all the way
through
you know people are less attached to the
characters than they are
to the the marketing of the franchise
which is maybe also a difference to what
used to be like where people got more
attached to the protagonist
yeah we were just interviewing another
filmmaker the other day and they talked
about how
in the nightmare on elm street movies
that freddie almost became a parody
eventually because it just it was like
this
you know sort of gimmick all of a sudden
so right interesting
but that's maybe maybe that's okay
because it's a joyful parody people who
are such
fans of his that then it's okay to make
them that much bigger than life same for
i think evil debt too is a total comedy
whereas evil
evil dead is kind of more serious i
think once you have people on board
i totally understand the impulse to kind
of take everything over the top and see
where it goes
it's just hard to come back from that
obviously once you've gone there
how do you rein it back in unless you
make a true uh
remake and restart the show like
halloween did or something like that
have you gone to any horror cons no
no but i want to they're actually i was
surprised uh
people are actually very polite yes they
were very polite and like
there wasn't at least the ones that i
attended there wasn't this weird sort of
la
like competitive vibe where i've gone to
other things that are maybe more
would say um high culture whatever and
that's not the case i just found that
very interesting yeah
i have that with horror fans that they
the ones that i talk to are very
soft-spoken
are very smart are very gentle
everything that you would imagine
they wouldn't be from the cliche you
know it's interesting
yeah i know i wonder what that is you
think that
whatever i mean i don't know there's
probably a million ways to analyze why
but
i was just taken aback i was surprised
yeah okay
what makes you a great horror director
what makes me a great horror director i
don't know if i am a great
horror director sorry to put that that
label on you
what i hope makes me a passable horror
director um is the same thing that i
hope would make me
a passable director in general which is
focus on
story focus on character which is so
lame to say because it's such a cliche
but it's just
so true that's that's what makes uh an
experience for the audience and then
the the shock and the horror and the
gore of it all
that's all kind of ornamentation on top
but the the basic structure
still has to be a very solid foundation
in storytelling and that
means to always be very aware where the
audience is
at any given moment in time what is the
information they're processing right now
what are the emotions that they are
might be fighting
that might be raging inside of them
hopefully if you've done
if you've done your job i think it's
almost like
resource management in terms of the
audience's
energy attention and emotional
involvement i think that's kind of the
backbone of any directing
you know it starts with the writing
obviously that script
has a certain structure to kind of it's
like this rollercoaster
um that the audience is being taken on
and then you are
as the director the person that takes
the blueprints of that roller coaster
by builds the roller coaster and then
finesses the roller coaster always with
the audience kind of
simulated in your head which is really
hard because you've said so long
with the script and with the characters
that you have almost lost
touch with what it's like to experience
it for the first time
and yet you are building it for people
that are experiencing it for the first
time
which to me the whole um which is why
the whole
test viewing process that i know many
filmmakers
despise to me is actually a really
important one
it's depressing and i want to kill
myself every time after a test screening
because you get all these
problems that you didn't even know you
had
and your film had and you felt pretty
good about it and after a test screening
you are sure to feel shitty about your
film
but it's so important because the first
time that an audience that sees it for
the first time
tells you their opinion and if you don't
listen you're kind of
lost and that took me a while to figure
out so i would i
i would hope that what makes me
a good director is how closely i can
simulate the audience experience in my
mind
years ago i had gone and gone to a few
of those test screenings where
people would just hand you the passes
you know on the street and they always
made sure that you weren't
in the entertainment industry and i
found that very interesting because
you're going to have a different
perspective
and this was probably like 15 years ago
so
my perspective on storytelling would be
much different than it is
right now right but yeah i remember just
the detail of why they wanted to know
certain things yeah ratings it's always
with these test
screenings what's so interesting to me
is that by the time that you do the test
screening
you've worked on for so long that you're
obsessing over these details
oh there's that one taken there where
she doesn't fully turn
it destroys the movie and then you test
screen the thing
and not only do they not have a problem
with that take
they have a problem with what something
much more basic and much more
fundamental
in the first act which is like oh i
don't think this should be a horror
movie this should be a musical
and you go like what are we talking but
that is how people consume
these things and same for me when a
friend gives me let's say a rough cut
and i give notes on that do i then want
to see
the final movie if i do
i always have the feeling that's the
same as the rough cut of course if i had
sat in the editing room with my friend
doing the notes i would know that this
is a completely different animal from
what i saw two months ago
but as in just as an audience i take in
what the rough story is what the rough
conflicts are
whether i like the characters or not and
i have no
real interest in whether that take is a
little bit
underdeveloped or over exposed or
whatever you know it's the broad rush
strokes
and that is something you have to try to
get back to as a director when you test
screen your movie and that's
really hurtful it really is a dangerous
difficult process to kind of get back
into that mindset
and then flip back out of it and be
detail-oriented again it's kind of a
schizophrenic
process a little bit yeah i wonder how
much
focus groups and things like that
whether it's product testing or whatever
are really that helpful or the fact that
you know you were there to
quote pick something apart right i
wonder i wonder yeah if you really
well my test screening that is not
really that big marketing test screening
it's more like a group of my friends
that see it for the first time where
know exactly what their tastes are
what they like what they don't like and
if someone loves
let's say this this kind of scene but
has a problem with that scene then i
better listen
to what that person has to say because
there's probably something in it which
to me is different from a big marketing
kind of survey where i don't know who
these people are there's still something
valuable in it to hear from the general
audience
kind of a thing but it's much more
valuable to have 10
hand-picked people that you also if you
do
a couple of test screenings different
stages of your film
that you have very much in mind whom to
invite
when who is the most helpful when whom
do i want to hear
from right after the shoot when i just
show them some dailies
is that the most helpful for that person
and how that person gives
feedback or is it more helpful to edit
the movie
polish it and then let that person see
the
cut right before i lock it you know
there are those people and those people
at some point after you've done it a
couple of times you kind of know you are
know your feedback people and when to go
to whom
i listened to a panel of prime writers
speak about things and they
had a question from the moderator and
she asked what scares you
you write about crime you write about
some very gruesome things
but in life what actually scares you and
they said the well being dry
not being able to come up with new ideas
uh-huh
i think three out of the panel the other
one said mimes
[Laughter]
that is true um what scares me i think
that is probably a very
writer oriented answer the well-being
dry because as a director
you don't have to start from scratch you
don't have to start with the empty page
where if you don't have an idea nothing
happens you know i always have
something to work off of and then it's
just a translation process
so that's why you don't hear about
director's block much yeah there's
writer's block
director's blog is not so much a thing
um i mean about that path
my biggest fear would be to to
[Music]
to be mediocre i think in
what i have to say to the world and not
to have anything to say to the world
i have that in a very different thing
with twitter
people that have something to say to the
world twice a day
i envy that i know i can't tweet because
with every tweet that i would write
i would think does the world need to
know this
and is this news to the world or is this
is there entertainment value
what is valuable about this thing that
i'm gonna throw out into the world
and the answer is always nothing and
that's why i don't tweet
you know um and and with movies it's
kind of the same now that there's
so much and that you just pull up
netflix and there are a couple they add
what 700 shows
a year or something crazy that at some
point you go like
does the world need my contribution to
that
if i weren't me and i didn't want to be
a director
would i say it's a life spent
well contributing the 700th and first
show episode of that show to netflix to
throw into this huge
ocean of stuff that already exists do i
just you know
throw away my life out of out of i don't
know what it is because that creative
bug
has got me but overall if i think about
what you could do with your life and how
you could
do something valuable is this the right
way to do it and
am i interesting enough to have enough
interesting things to say to the world
to
justify spending my life that way and
the answer to that being no
is probably what scares me the most in
terms of creative
like my creative life otherwise mimes
and clowns are definitely out there yeah
yeah i find that interesting too about
the twitter
analogy because i've seen people who
seen ladies tweet about hey i just
finished my gynecology appointment and
you're like you know i don't really need
to know that
but i think that people have a point to
everything they tweet and again it's the
same with storytelling
so there's some either thing that they
want to get out there
agenda message whatever or just a cool
story to be told and i think it's the
same with twitter there
there's some type of an agenda to what
the tweet is even if it's
hey guys this is great coffee at this
place or you know whatever
right but um maybe it goes back to
the filter of seeing what your message
or your
story is and how you view it because
some people think that everything they
do
needs to be broadcasts and others
are more hesitant that makes a lot of
sense that that maybe goes back to that
i simulate the audience in my head too
much from
from directing and from storytelling i
do the same with my tweets but i go like
what
would my audience be and how would they
process this and
how would it be interesting to them
which may be a lot of people that
we don't do because they're not as
obsessed with the audience reaction
but it's more like to put it out into
the world and that's it and that's fine
which is a beautiful mindset maybe i
should try to get back to that to not
overthink it but just to kind of
pump something out into the world and be
happy about it what a beautiful mindset
to think that the world is interested
whether you just had a gynecology
appointment or not you know
great yeah but hard to get here
everything looks good okay thanks
are you where you planned to be right
now for filmmaking with your career
am i where i plan to be i think i always
in my younger years always saw myself as
a writer director because that to me was
like
the total creator where's the directors
just the translator of someone else's
inspiration um so no i'm not i'm not
where i
saw myself or wished myself or am even
wishing myself
right now it's just that writing is so
hard and i have such respect
for writers that do that to themselves
and the the stakes of that of you
working on something for years
that then might or might not get made or
might or might not even turn out well
um it's kind of more than i can i can
bear with my fragile creative ego so i'm
kind of playing it safe
by staying in the in the directing world
which i probably should thinking about
it now i probably
should write again and and try try more
of that because i think that the
fulfillment that you get from seeing
your story not just the way it's told on
screen but
your story from from the first seed is
something that might
must be spectacular that i've only had
was my very first movie
ever um where i hadn't even written the
script but it was a found footage
thing that just came to be um but to
know that these characters
would not exist without me having had
the idea for them
was incredible and i haven't had that
since because these characters
that i now bring to life they are
already jumping off the page and just
putting them on the screen so they would
exist in some other incarnation one way
or the other
so again it goes back to for me being
that the writer being the real
creative driving force behind any
storytelling
and then the format is just what the
director is involved i think um
it's also the turbulence that goes along
with writing and i was watching a
documentary that compared
daschle hammett and raymond chandler and
their lives
and their lives had been you know
turbulent
for different reasons but it was very um
maybe the turbulence of the writing
contributed to the the depth of the
stories
right you know and uh with directing
some of that you're like you said you're
taking other people's
maybe even turbulence and you're
bringing it to life but you don't have
to necessarily
experience all that yeah and the risk
you don't take the risk of just wasting
a lot of time
you know if i if i get sent a script and
it's financed then i know the time that
i
spend on it right now will translate
into most of the time
will translate into a finished product
on screen
whereas if i sit down at the computer
with a blank page
and i start you know writing scene one
day so and so
the chances of that actually ending up
on screen
one day are so minuscule so minuscule
which i think you just have to be either
ignorant of to do it or
be completely delusional to do it anyway
at
great you know more power to the people
that can do that i get
demotivated i think too quickly if i
hear the numbers
some producers said to me that in their
company which produced a lot back then
they have about eight percent of what
makes it into the final stages of
development that they are really
developing with the full intention of
making it to the screen eight percent of
that makes it to the screen
and only a minuscule percentage of what
they start developing
makes it into the final stages so really
someone and i don't want to demotivate
anyone i think any writer
has to be so driven any way that the
numbers don't matter and they just
write it because they have to write it
because otherwise it'll tear them apart
but if you did look at the numbers i
think you would you would try to do
something
other than start writing a script from
scratch and i know that's exactly where
i'm going wrong and i should
find the courage again to just do it for
the creative outlet and i just haven't
in a couple of years
so that's the answer to do i find myself
where i wanted to be
no but i also have to earn a living
which would be really hard if i now took
a year or two to write a script that
then might or might not ever get made
you know so like real life just kind of
kicks in at some point
right right if you look at a lot of the
writers that continually put their work
out there
and the turbulence that went through it
you know maybe it's it's just being more
of a realist
yeah pragmatic or you know just i wonder
if realism and pragmatism is like the
big enemy of
the creative spark that you almost have
to fight that as much as you can
or look it straight in the eye and say i
know that i might
live under a bridge in a year because i
can't pay my rent
but it doesn't matter because i'd rather
live under a bridge and do creatively
what i was born to do
than live in a cozy apartment and be
miserable because i'm not doing that i
think it's either of those
of those two things probably yeah
yeah i mean if uh speaking of another
like l.a based writer
i know dashiell hammett was in the bay
area but um
you know charles bukowski you know just
yes
you know brilliant person but the
turbulence that came out of that and and
what comes first um the turbulent sort
of mind
with amazing ideas and stories or or
the process of doing something over and
over again and being rejected and then
that brings out the turbulence i don't
know right like chicken or the egg type
but that's also part of the pragmatism
we're talking about then
i'm i know i'm self-aware enough to know
that i'm not a buckowski
that i'm not a genius with a turbulent
story that
you know i'm probably a pretty if you
look at a pretty mediocre writer
so factoring that into my chances of
success if i knew i were a genius writer
i would take the chance
but knowing that i'm i'm i have friends
that are
so much better writers that don't get
anywhere and
really should that it would take a lot
of ego for me to suddenly say you know
what i have to say something to the
world that trumps all that and is going
to surpass all that
i wish i could tell you something more
inspirational then i'm too afraid to
write
but at the moment that's kind of the
reason why i just direct
so maybe the inspirational thing would
be if you if you still have that
energy in you and that fight to to make
your story
hurt amazing and go for it i would say
well i think even with raymond chandler
wasn't he fired from his oil
job so it kind of he was in a spot where
he was ready to do it so again it was
sort of like
you know life sort of kind of stripped
everything away
right yeah i would imagine that's the
case for many people
and that's why you see people with these
dual careers you know that the create
creative path presents itself when the
pragmatic
real life path comes to a difficult spot
kind of a thing
yeah you know and comparing those two
men's lives
i think raymond chandler came from more
impoverished means and he actually
became
you know he ended up living in la jolla
you know he sort of like wrote with sort
of
she was sort of the enemy of the one
percent sort of in his writing you know
and here he
almost kind of became and it's just so
very interesting right and uh
and unfortunately daschle ham it was i
guess um
taken out by uh you know the the marx
yeah and the red scare and was
blacklisted and
uh do you ever think that we'll see
anything like that in our our time again
you know
so artists so unimaginable that we'll go
through another
full-blown mccarthy area era
but then everything might be leading up
to it because a lot of the things
without going political but a lot of the
things that are happening right now i
never would have thought
we will ever see again in in the us just
as in germany
or other parts of europe that should
really know better especially germany
there's no excuse with that history
for any move to the right and it's crazy
so i guess anything is possible and and
to become
politically more interested i was
completely disinterested in politics i
have to admit
um before the trump era because it
always felt everything
is kind of going into a
borderline reasonable direction and the
minutia of it all seemed very
boring very you know um that
definitely has changed you know um
because it's a daily
soap opera now that it's actually
thrilling um to watch but it's also
it's also unimaginable that we are that
we are
watching that so i think you have a good
point that it's totally possible that
that will happen again and maybe not
with exactly the same methods maybe a
little bit more subtle so that
you don't hit those buttons where we are
now more aware of
censorship and of blacklisting and all
that kind of stuff but we are also more
aware of fascism and there are still
signs of that raising its head again so
i don't know but let's keep an eye out i
would say yeah you know there's a quote
and forgive me i don't know who it's
from but it says something like beware
of artists
they can move between groups like
they're the most dangerous and
i i'm butchering the quote but i found
it very interesting that
artists would be uh scary
for i guess just because of what they
create and and the effect on the masses
right and they just said how they can
move between sort of classes and groups
easily and that that is actually the
most
sort of terrifying i don't know yeah
butchering yeah
it's interesting because i was the first
thought that i had when
this political change happened that now
happened was that i
felt really bad for the arts
because in my mind storytelling was
always
this tradition that bundles our values
and our experiences and everything we
have to pass on
to the next generation in terms what's
in terms of what's
right and what's decent and what's
important and we put that into a story
and then we pass it on and that's been
going on for centuries and centuries
you know with films for 100 years and
yet
what happened happened which basically
politically
people are getting to power that are
defying
every value that we've been passing on
in terms of decency in terms of
um so does that mean that storytelling
is
actually far less powerful than i always
thought
because if stories had millennia to
instil
instill some kind of basic level of
of compassion and decency and all that
in us which is what almost every
almost every story is is talking about
now is talking about values of
of freedom and tolerance and all these
things there are very few stories that
talk
positively about fascism or about you
know
screwing over the weakest part of
society and all that
so how is it possible that someone can
come in
not just trump all over the world which
makes it even scarier
wipe all that away every
the disney movie we've been showing our
children to kind of get them to be good
people
um and within a couple of months uh
dismantle
that whole thing like what does what
does that say about
the power of story i don't know what the
answer to that is but it's
i have less faith and storytelling than
i used to before this era for sure
and i hope that that will change and
hopefully storytelling can contribute to
some kind of age of reason being ushered
back in
um
how do you create a horror protagonist
again i would say the same way you
create
any other protagonist which means
your goal is to have the audience
build a relationship with that person
that they are not
ambivalent about him or her that can
hate her or love him or whatever but
there has to be some kind of emotional
connection because
otherwise none of the horror set pieces
that follow
will mean anything because it happens to
a person we don't care about so we need
the audience needs to care
you know and then the question is how do
you achieve that there is the whole
save the cat kind of concept that you
have to have that one moment
where the protagonist displays some kind
of humanity where i see myself i
recognize myself in that person
or i you know i kind of want that person
to be okay and like that person
um there's humor which is a great weapon
i think to make the audience
kind of identify with a person but it's
hard and it's
very rarely done like if i have to
if i'd have to tell you horror
protagonists right now where that is the
case i'd have
difficulties with that you know and then
you see
script i just read a script by a friend
of mine for for a pilot
where she achieves that in the first two
pages
which in that case was very simple if
you look at it if someone has done it
and done it well it's so it's so simple
it's basically a girl
in a college environment who is doing
and
has big stage pride and is going to
their talent
show their open mic thing to do a
political
art thing and you love her so much i
think because
you can identify with that fear to go up
in front of everybody
but she does it anyway because of her
conviction because she cares so much
and she cares about bees in that case
she's the torment
of the bees is something that she just
has to tell
her to the world because she can't bear
how bees are treated
so that combination of someone will look
social death straight in the eye to save
bees
i was like that girl i'm on board with
as a protagonist even if she on page
three starts killing people
i would still go like you go girl you
know
and that's a huge huge goal and that's i
think not at
all uh genre dependent that's a very
interesting question if you ask
other horror filmmakers if they have
an angle on how they establish their
protagonist that is influenced
by the fact that they're working in
horror i know that that's not the case
for me
for sure i think with jamie lee curtis's
character it seemed like she was
pretty much well liked through through
you know in halloween that's true
definitely was the darling um that'd be
interesting to dissect
why that was the case like why do people
gravitate
to some characters because i there i
couldn't tell you a kind of save the cat
moment for example when she was
established
necessarily which are other horror
protagonists that you feel strongly
about do they have a strong sympathy
for well carrie i always felt carried
but i don't think
i think kerry was more polarizing
because people thought she was creepy so
she quote deserved it
i think unfortunately that's a mob
mentality but that is okay too because
it's an emotion and an
investment that that half of the
audience hates kerry and the other
half loves carrie that is goal achieved
you know you don't need 100
for the audience to love her you just
want to keep the number of people that
are indifferent towards your protagonist
as low as possible
you know and kerry is a great example
where i think that was
very very successfully done for sure
yeah right right and um linda blair
i think she was more more liked you know
she was
sort of she wasn't her fault that she
was possessed
but then linda blair and the exorcist is
is
like a type if if you had to tell me
what that girl was really
like i don't think it's a very
interesting personality where you go
like oh
she came so to life as a human being
that i can't get her out of my head
like you could have the the stuff that
happened to her was so horrendous
that if you had that happen to any child
it would probably have
that effect you know so i don't even
know
if the or if even the shining if i go
through there there are not many
there are not many movies that
successfully do that period
but i think they're probably even less
in in horror
and if i had to speculate i would say
that has to do with
a misguided focus on horror set pieces
that we think a good horror movie is
made of great horror set pieces which is
true
um but that the character development is
overlooked in that case if i if i um
look at the sixth sense for example
that boy and his torment to me worked so
well if that if there had been no ghosts
and was just about that boy
i would still care about that boy
because he was he was so well acted was
so well directed it was so well written
that i cared by the time that the scary
stuff
started happening or just to stick with
shyamalan
unbreakable i know has this one moment
in the very beginning where the boy was
yearning to spend time with his father
the father is calling him and he's on a
playground playing soccer with his
friends
and he goes like guys guys i gotta go i
have to hang out with my father and then
he turns around again and goes i'm going
to spend time with my dad
it was so i could cry right now it was
so heartbreaking it was so beautiful
and just from those two lines i care you
know
and was that even the question what was
the question oh the well how do you make
a great horror protagonist right
yes um yeah just make me ideally make me
fall in love with a character and i
think that's
much like in real life sometimes one
moment makes you
fall in love with someone and go like i
care about that person because i've seen
a vulnerability or
whatever it is that that moment did if
you can create that
with your protagonist that's a huge
achievement that will
pay off hugely throughout your movie i
think
right and even when they have ugly
moments because everybody does you could
see someone in one moment
and they're having the worst day
possible and then you're gonna brand
that person
as a horrible human being every time you
see them because that was your first
right but with the movie yeah we get a
chance to see
a better build up yeah you see that in
documentaries about
serial killers they always show that
picture of the serial killer as a child
right done you know because you're like
no that's the starting point
that innocence and then something
happened to them that
made them into this monster but it's
such a such an easy trick to just do
that but it works for everybody because
it's this cute child that deserve better
than to be turned into a serial killer
yeah that's a great analogy yeah same
mechanism i think
right right and so then yeah you see
that that photo and then you hear
sort of you know the hard life or
whatever that went with it and so then
you soften toward the person
everything that happens after that you
link back to that
you know even though they had like seven
bodies buried
in the backyard but they you saw yeah
you see the little child and then you
yeah think how could they yeah eileen
warnos i think the great documentary
yeah making up a serial killer i was
just thinking about her i was thinking
when you talk about i was like she's
talking about alienware because they did
that they had this great picture of her
and then they that came along with she
had to sleep out in the car in the snow
and people brought it doesn't matter
what she does after that you know she
killed seven people
i don't care and with her you know it's
it's her
tragedy that i'm watching from then on
and it's really just it takes less than
20 seconds to do it
and it's such a big payoff and that's
why it's so crazy to me that most movies
that i watch
do either not invest those 20 seconds or
haven't found
a good way to make me care about the
protagonist before they take me on this
journey
or ted bundy who was charming incredibly
bright
had a high emotional iq didn't he act as
his own attorney in court i mean he
just so it's he's more forgivable
somehow is that is that it i don't know
to me bundy is because of those things
more fascinating
but it doesn't make him any less of a
monster the part that
when when i read about it was that he
worked on for a suicide hotline
and saved people's lives and then he
turned to a serial killer
so that part suicide hotline where he
genuinely saved people's lives on the
phone
now i care all the other stuff that he
was brilliant and he represented himself
in court
that is all still psychopath stuff that
is interesting it makes him such a
such an evergreen as a serial killer i
could watch bundy stuff
day and night i'm obsessed with that man
but i still wouldn't
care for him as much as i care for
eileen warnos after that
childhood picture if i hadn't heard that
piece about the suicide hotline you know
where's john gwen gacy maybe you know
yeah i think you know the whole the the
the physical i hate to go there but are
we blinded by that
in terms of our our our protagonists and
antagonists
and the whole clown thing and it was
great you know
whereas bundy you probably you put a
modern day one
many women would have fallen for it it'd
be very easy right
and maybe that's what makes it even more
terrifying you see someone a certain way
you think okay yeah that
could be that quote serial killer
composite
right but someone like no could never no
way
well it's always so crazy to me that
when when you hear
people tell their stories you are
on their side with all crime shows i
always have there's this meek person
let's say btk the btk killer this meek
person
in court that says yes sir sorry sir oh
yes sir
and you can't help but liking him and
you know that he has like
hung children from the ceiling and let
them suffocate and then
you know crazy stuff but you can't bring
those two things together i had that
with a friend of mine got murdered in
germany and
in film school and i went to the trial
and saw the person that shot him and
i could not bring myself to hate that
guy even though i should have
because he was telling his story from
his point of view
you know and i just couldn't put those
two
things together and i think that is
maybe a lesson in storytelling but it's
all about
point of view and about the angle and
what you spend time on obviously
in that case they suddenly spent a lot
of time on his childhood
where before that i was only spending
time my energy on the moment of my
friend getting murdered but it depends
on where you start that story
and how much emphasis you put on stuff
and maybe got to bring that back to
horror movies a lot of horror movies
seem to
not look not spend a lot of time on that
character development but
rush to the first set piece as quickly
as possible and you always have the
opening sequence where this family with
the boxes are standing in front of the
old spoopy house that they just
inherited or whatever
we go like really yeah but i think they
would be
they would be better served spending
more time on that which again doesn't
have to be much time even but to
to hammer home that moment that i can
put my finger on in the script and go
like this is the moment that is going to
make
my audience fall in love with my
protagonist that should almost be a
requirement for every scene
show me that moment
and you almost shouldn't read on if you
can't put your finger on that moment
because you know that something is wrong
with that script that sounds harsh but i
think we would
get much better movies if that were a
requirement
for the writer to point out the point
where
he or she thinks the audience will fall
in love with the protagonist or hate the
programs
or develop some emotional attachment
to the protagonist
i'm definitely glad that i was allowed
to grow up
before instagram because if i look we
just had an au pair a 19 year old from
germany
it was amazing to see her life just for
a couple of weeks
because so much energy and thought
is put into the side job that you have
24 7 of being a pr agent for yourself
because you
owe it you have to present yourself to
your peers through instagram
i don't think that not having an
instagram account is an option even
you'd be an outcast and a crazy person
immediately
and that means you have to not only
update your own account but you also
have to make sure to
like your friends things quickly and
because it says something about your
friendship
and they have totally internalized that
and they are great at it
but it must be so stressful if i imagine
i had had my normal childhood and gone
to school and all that
and then i also have to moonlight as a
pr
expert i would have gone nuts so
i could imagine that that contributes to
the the nervous energy out there of
of creating spectacles that will bring
people's attention to what you're doing
and if you can't do that in a positive
way
do it in a negative way um that's that's
scary
yeah i'm glad instagram wasn't around
when i was a teenager too
yeah just the pressure of it and if
everybody feels pressure whether they're
the most popular
to the most uh outcast of
sort of the school or whatever and you
have to interpret everything why did my
friend
not like my photograph so so are we not
like
the the value of the friendships there
seems to be like a stock market market
of value of friendships all the time
that rise and fall by likes collected
but to even survey that is a full-time
job you know
so it's just so much time and energy and
thought process being put
into that and i don't know how much
positive comes out of that i can see a
lot of positive
uh things with social media with the
internet obviously i wouldn't want to
live in times
before the internet but i don't know how
much positive things come
out of this this this
self-presentational kind of instagram
thing but i'm also too old obviously too
to really appreciate it i guess yeah but
maybe that's a good thing yeah i'm i'm
at peace with that i mean we put our
stuff on instagram but it's not really
lifestyle related
right you know it's also not you as a
person right right which is
which is wonderful so
at this stage of your career how do you
measure your own success
how do i measure my own success i have
to admit we just talked about social
media
um that what is fun is that you have a
direct feedback loop
from your audience audience on twitter
so i do
read twitter and their comments because
the great thing is that that people that
are posting on twitter
don't think that you're reading it so
it's really
it's the purest feedback you can get
more
than i get from my family or from my
agents or from
anyone ever the most honest opinion
um is twitter and what is great about it
too which
you always forget is kind of the
innocence and the
the lack of cynicism with which a
general audience outside of
hollywood consumes your stuff because
you are
in in this bubble of other storytellers
and filmmakers and
and you spend your life on that and you
develop your stuff in that and they test
view it
you're always in this mindset of what is
new what is cutting edge what is
unpredictable pop up all that stuff and
then you put it out there
and you realize that the the scene that
you thought was the most generic and you
were slightly embarrassed by
people get so excited about and we
did an episode of fear the walking dead
and there was someone's head getting
chopped off some zombies head getting
chopped off
and that is suddenly the most exciting
moment for everybody and
it it reminds me of this pure joy of
of consuming cinema that i i think i
threw out the window and sacrificed when
i went to film school
because that was taken from me the
actual watching a movie as a movie and
enjoying it as a movie and not always
thinking am i cool and intellectual
in liking this or not like because you
either liked something you didn't like
something
um so that's always a real interesting
thing to kind of get that reaction so a
lot of how i judge my success
is how thrilled or enthusiastic
are people on twitter as individuals i
don't even know if there are 10 people
of them out there or
a thousand people it almost doesn't
matter because it's
it's it goes back to why you originally
wanted to tell stories to evoke
a genuine emotion in someone if it's
just that one person
that says my favorite movie is and then
it's my movie which seems to happen with
i did that as a test to just type in
some random indie movie
that i didn't make to just see if it's
somebody's favorite movie
and it is you almost can't put a movie
title into twitter that someone has not
said it's their new favorite movie
and that's the most beautiful thing in
the world to think that
i not because i'm special or a great
filmmaker but just by the virtue of
having made
a movie i created someone's favorite
movie
that's almost enough of a success to to
justify
wanting to make movies all over again do
you respond you said
you do respond no oh you don't okay no
i've
done that in the in the at the very
beginning because i thought oh how cool
would it have been
when i was young um that the filmmaker
actually
responds yeah that would have blown my
mind so i did that in the beginning
but it never ends well because you can't
live live up to that because
which i totally understand that for an
audience it's hard
to have that contact and then not have
that contact anymore
so then you're getting chris in that
case chris i'm still getting christmas
emails from
someone i was in touch with 2010 and the
first years i still wrote back but then
how do you you know
so and especially with negative stuff
like never and it's always a mistake to
respond in any way
to negative stuff because you can't
you can't win you know other than
you can maybe you could if you wanted to
respond you could respond
positively and say good point i see your
criticism
but to defend yourself is always a
mistake
and we were in film school we were
prepped really well for that because we
made our
short films and then we presented them
to the class and we had to sit
in front of the screen and kind of look
at the look at your class and you
weren't allowed
to respond they would throw all their
criticism at you
and your only exercise was to say
thank you for the for the criticism not
justify anything not say anything
that was the greatest prep in the world
because
in real life you also don't get to i
mean on twitter you might if you wanted
to you could reply to two or three
people
but there are tens of thousands of other
people whom you don't get to respond
to like your thing that you made and put
out there
and ask them to donate two years of to
do hours of their lifetime to
has to speak for itself you don't get
any
directors commentary on that stuff or
any you know q and a afterwards where
you get to justify stuff
so you better make sure that you say
everything that you needed to say
in the main piece that's why again why
test screenings to me
among friends or among a small group of
people are so important because there
you still
get to react but once you shoot it out
into the world
that's it you're done and it's really
hard it's really hard to
have people for example misunderstand
stuff and say stuff about your movie
where you're like you misunderstand the
entire and some of them love the movie
but understand it completely wrong and
you want to say like no that's not at
all but you don't get to that's that's
kind of their privilege
to you had the privilege that they
listened to you for two hours
and now it's their private privilege
that for the rest of your life they're
allowed to say whatever they want about
your movie and you have to take it
whether you
listen to it or not is a different thing
but you don't get to reply
but seems fair to me in the end is that
common
to have a class in film school where
you're sort of
allowed to be like the peanut gallery so
to speak is allowed to kind of throw
food at you a little bit at the film
school i went to
it was that's very progressive from the
very yeah yeah maybe
maybe this is in germany no it was here
here oh
yeah um and it was good that we weren't
allowed i remember that one
in the in the beginning maybe there were
classes where we were still
allowed to answer and one of my fellow
directors sweetest guy super talented
said the film that ended the the
sentence that ended his film school
career
um and he said to someone saying
something oh that's what i was going for
that's what i was
wanting to do but i didn't think that my
cinematographer
and my editor were capable of it
and you just could feel the silence and
for the next two and a half years
nobody wanted to to work with them and i
know that's not how he meant it right
he meant it in terms of that it could be
done in the time frame that the school
gives
sure with the equipment that this but
there he didn't get a second shot at it
he was like
he had the from then on out the were the
least talented cinematographers the ones
that no one else wanted to team up with
it echoed through so i was always kind
of glad that the mandate for the other
lesson was you don't get to respond
because then you can put
can't put your foot in your mouth at
least
where would you like to go next where
would i
like to go next um
i definitely would like to make another
feature but i also want to do tv i think
we live in times now where
filmmakers have to do both
two completely different worlds but i
would love to do
both and just the same as always i just
want to find a great script
where i have the feeling i haven't read
the story before and there's just a copy
of something that i've already
read which is hard because obviously
there are bigger and
better filmmakers than me that get those
scripts first so my approach has to be a
little bit of a different one if i just
wait and sit sit and wait that might
never happen so i kind of have to team
up with
writers to develop it and bring bring
the first ideas
uh out there so that it is actually mine
and i can direct it rather than other
people
um i'd probably have to be more
proactive in that than i
used to be in the past but that's where
i want to go next you know
when you say proactive what does that
entail because
you know you think about having to push
a career forward in hollywood and
kind of think of like this this pushy
agenda and if that's not in you
as a person because it's kind of like a
used car salesman feeling to it
how do you how do you be proactive when
that goes against your nature
well i would say proactive first on the
creative level that doesn't yet
mean to talk to any producers or any
buyers or any whatever whatever because
true i i wouldn't know how to do that
and then there are people for that too
but it's obviously a different mindset
if i just say i am the director for hire
and i'm waiting for my agent to send me
a script
you know that there is a script that i
read and say this is great that i
then get to direct the chances are
pretty slim whereas
if i have an idea that i like
and i team up with a writer and say do
you like this idea
should we develop this together and we
even get it into
treatment form it doesn't even have to
be a script if we just write
five pages of it then we can take that
out and talk to people and say here's
the idea
which again should speak for itself i
shouldn't have to be
a used car salesman that does a great
presenting job you know
but ideally the idea is kind of
captivating um
enough and then hopefully things would
develop from there that the
the company that we've pitched it to are
paying for a first draft
and things are going on their way and
the great thing is that i'm
from the very beginning attached as a
director i don't have to
go to the job interview and tell them my
vision of whatever
to win it over other directors that are
doing the same but i am
as one of the creators i'm on board from
the very beginning
i think that's how that would have to be
done for someone in my position who is
not a huge name
in directing spielberg obviously doesn't
have to do that because he gets the good
project
sent but i have to kind of create a
little bit more so i think that's the
proactive
thing it's just to create ideas myself
more than i have in the past
because in the past the the credo was
let's only do green lit projects meaning
projects that are already being financed
and are ready to go
because developing takes so long that
you spend years of not getting paid
for then the project to maybe fall apart
which is
a risk that's why in the past i always
was hired for greenlit projects that
then went
but you only get a certain quality of
material
like that you know um so to to generate
the idea yourself has these two i think
these
two advantages one is you already like
the seed of it all which is huge which
is hard to find if you are
snobby about it and you are already
attached as the creative
force behind it so those are two great
great starting points
do you really think there are stories
that have not been done before
of course that it goes back to every
story has been told but
not every story has been told in
new and original enough ways that make
me
either not recognize it as a story that
has already been told
or that makes me forget that it's a
story that has been told so
it's just a a rephrasing of the
telling a new story maybe you're not
telling a news story um
but you are it's like cooking right it's
like you might not
have a completely new you might not
suddenly eat things
that have never been eaten before i
don't suddenly eat
make a dinner out of plastic and metal
and wood i'm still using vegetables and
whatever
but the recipe might be a completely new
one and when people
eat it it's an experience that they
haven't had
that way that's basically all i'm
looking for whereas
a lot of scripts that you get are
experiences that you've already had
better and stronger and it's a weaker
copy
of that and that's kind of what you want
to avoid
right what are your thoughts of making a
living as a film director in 2019
is it possible is it doable is it more
so
with television my thoughts on making a
living as a filmmaker in 2010 it's
definitely possible because people are
people are doing it i think it's a
great time especially for female
filmmakers
which you can't point out
enough that if i've seen my my director
female director friends over the past
years
that have always bumped up against some
wall of subtle sexism that was just only
so
far they went they were smarter than
us male filmmakers and they were more
committed and yet if you saw the numbers
they just didn't get to direct the
projects they should have
and i think that is very much over right
now all my
female directing filmmakers they are
having
stellar careers one of them just had a
commercial during the super bowl
you know it's out of end and fast out of
short films
one day and heading tv shows
the next day so for female filmmakers i
don't know if i've
i've been alive during a better
period that comes with
it's it's deserved counterpart that it's
slightly harder
for me that i'm not a female filmmaker
right now to find
tv projects because it's just the time
luckily
it's taken long enough off the female
filmmaker no show can afford
this this atrocity that they that
happened before where it was like a
12 episodes made by 12 white male
filmmakers
you know when that was still the case it
was easy for me to find a job
but luckily we're more woke now you know
so um i i kind of see it get a little
bit of the taste of what that must have
been like where it's just
hard to get that job what it must have
been like for them
for you know years and years and years
and years and i've only done it for
a year or two since that kind of whole
harvey weinstein
thing kind of happened and a lot of good
stuff came out of
all of that you know in terms of society
changes
but yeah i would say for female
filmmakers this is
this is the time and i hope that it's
not just a fashion
that will reverse itself quickly but
that we really have
um started a new era which also comes
just with
different stories being told differently
like i
i don't know if that's politically
correct to say but i have the feeling
that
movies projects that are directed by
female directors oftentimes
they have a different feel to what their
male counterpart would have done with it
and i think that's such a treasure for
society to be exposed
to both rather than just to the male
perspective that we've been living with
for
400 years how does the director break
into television
how does a director break into
television i think that is a very good
question that i don't have an answer for
um because it's that catch-22 that you
sometimes bump up against that you have
have to have done they want you to have
done it before but obviously there has
to be
the point where you do it for the first
time right you have to break into
it somehow i was lucky in that my first
uh episodes that i ever got were for bbc
america
and there were there was a group of
incredibly
smart and inspirational uh women at the
helm and they wanted
feature filmmakers to them it was an
asset that i hadn't done tv anymore
before but that's probably a very
forward
thinking a courageous thing that you
don't necessarily find
everywhere most most channels want
people that have done tv before and same
for pilot directing
um you are either a pilot director
meaning you have directed a pilot again
which
before which makes you eligible for
being hired to direct another pilot
or you're not i'm not a pilot director
because i haven't done a pilot before
so i don't get to direct pilots it's a
mystery to me how i'm supposed to become
a pilot director
so i totally understand if other
filmmakers to them it's a mystery how to
break into tv
i have no idea a miracle has to happen
what was the bbc project it was called
intruders
it was about reincarnation i was glenn
morgan the showrunner of x-files was the
showrunner
it had mira sovino in it um james frayne
and oh most importantly millie brown
who then rose to stardom in stranger
things
that's the main the main girl right
right who is absolutely
incredible and it was based on a british
book very good book
um but for some reason it didn't really
catch on and was canceled after one
season but to me was great because i got
to make
four episodes it was eight episodes
altogether it was eduardo sanchez of the
blair witch project who did the first
four
and i did the last four so that was kind
of great to really get the hang of the
tv
style which is so different from movies
you know to be able to
practice that over four episodes i was
really lucky there
and it was shot in the uk in vancouver
ah okay interesting what do you see as
the difference between
british television and not comedies of
course
there's definitely a difference in humor
but uh something that's supernatural or
horror based
versus uh american or maybe there's no
difference
i enjoyed the bbc's i mean everything
they do it's excellent documentaries
yeah i mean if you watch killing eve
which is my favorite
show at the moment which is incredible i
think that illustrates that that
point that characters everything more
than anything else and i think the brits
really have that
down they don't their actors are not the
most moderately looking people there are
people that we believe
as real people and they are not worried
to let them have
negative sides to them so they're very
relatable and much more
interesting to watch and then british
actors i think also
approach the craft differently than
than american actors so it's a different
it's a different vibe so i love the
british
not just for what what they do is that
they only do a couple of episodes they
do it brilliantly
and then they're out of there it's kind
of the opposite of the american waywards
like we have
something that we will beat to death
over eight seasons now
if you look at the office and the
original office which was a complete
genius
has what 10 10 episodes or something
like
that's that's it and they quit on the
height of their success ricky gervais
was like done with that i've given this
everything that i had in me boom i don't
know
how they where they get that integrity
because the money aspect is still there
obviously
but then the us remade it into what
which was also a great show
but into eight ten seasons of the office
you know um same with fleabag or with
all these great shows they just don't
overdo it and that's why every as an
audience member i feel
my time is really appreciated because
they put all their ideas and all their
jokes and everything that just makes it
brilliant into a shorter amount of time
because i have less episodes it's more
bundled and i don't feel like it's
dragged out whereas with a lot of the
american shows i have and i don't want
to
poo poo on american shows yeah or write
other things but you have the feeling
there's
there are one or two ideas in there and
the rest
is stretched out you know so here's the
plot point for this episode
and the rest is they would call it
character develop but
oftentimes it's just wasting your time
whereas the british stuff is like here
are eight plot developments or character
developments in 45 minutes
so it's just a much more
i don't know it's a it's a it's a in
more interesting format to me
you had said with the british actors
maybe their approach
to the characters might be slightly
different than american
do you think they get more theater
training i think it's used to being in
front of a live audience and it's
there's a different presence yeah very
much i think it's also that i think
method acting is very much an
american thing whereas what someone said
i don't know how true that is or not is
that
the american way of acting is from the
inside out from the emotion
out and the british acting is from the
outside
in which is interesting because the
american acting if you just describe it
like that
sounds like it's more has more integrity
than
kind of pretending a physical presence
and then have that
inform the character but i think that's
what a lot of the british
actors do that they figure out the
physicality of something and then let
that inform
how they feel about it whereas the
american way is the other way around
and as a director what's interesting
first of all
every british actor i've ever worked
with and i don't want to generalize
but they've been great to work with the
most
modest focused humble people ever and i
think that's
partly the theater education but also
that the star system over there
is a different one they see themselves
as actors not as celebrities or
personalities
and then because you are you are kind of
working with them on something that
comes from the outside in
they are much less sensitive to
adjustments sometimes with american
actors
because you're basically your your
workshop
is their psyche and their emotions and
all that from
it's very sensitive subject matter
because if you
if you if you give them an adjustment
that basically means that you ask them
to
feel differently about something right
and why they feel about something a
certain way
is their entire programming their entire
dna their entire life so far
so you giving them an adjustment goes
right into all that so it's very very
deep
whereas with the british way of acting
that
ego isn't attached to that it was just
kind of one thing they tried out this
way if you want an adjustment they'll
try something else
and then they will tell you how that
makes them feel and then you can work
from there
so it's weird that that if i hear myself
talk about it it seems like the more
superficial way of working
and yet the effects are are very very
strong and very very fun
i don't know why that is it's really
interesting observation
i think i have a follow-up for that
that's really fascinating i wouldn't
yeah
you would think it would be different
because it is internal
going it's the reverse and and how that
actually may work
that the internal one is is the higher
art of acting than the other one right
but it's
in practice it's not with the results
that you get
yeah maybe that's also that i'm just
totally making stuff up i know
very little about the acting experience
but that
there must be a lot of energy that is
being lost
on creating that emotion that then we
don't necessarily see
whereas with the british way of acting
all the energy because it's from the
outside in
is something we we see there's not as
much energy
lost in the underbelly of invisibility
yeah
whereas you get the results immediately
and i don't want to speak against method
acting i think it's it's wonderful but
it's a different it's definitely a
different
experience yeah what are the advantages
and disadvantages of being a studio
director for hire and disadvantages of
being a director for hire
the big advantage is that you get a
paycheck and you get residuals
and you can live uh
on that and be a filmmaker full-time
which is huge there's nothing
nothing negative about that
the negatives are that you have
very little influence
[Music]
in especially with tv in the creative
development process
because you are the director you're not
seen as the
filmmaker necessarily but you're hired
to do the focused task of directing and
the development has been done by the
writers
and by the showrunners um
and then you you it's a total lottery if
you run into
great executives that are super smart
and and i've had that where constantly
think wow i haven't thought about it
that way that's amazing where they're a
real asset to the project
or if you run into people that must be
friends of a friend of someone that
hired them have no idea about story
structure
no real interest in story structure but
sometimes just like
to hear themselves talk or have to give
notes because that is their job
and you always have to work around the
notes you can't just say
that's the dumbest thing i've ever heard
no we're not doing that you always have
to say
okay this is how we are addressing blah
blah blah and a lot of
it then becomes politics you're suddenly
halfway a diplomat
trying to to protect the project
against notes that you clearly feel are
harmful
while giving the executive the feeling
that they
have a positive impact on the on the
project which you don't have to deal
with
in independent filmmaking so it's really
a clear trade-off
they give you the money to do something
which is extremely comfortable not
having to raise money
to make your movie which is such a which
bogs you down in independent filmmaking
um but they want to be heard and there's
a whole
hierarchy of people that want to be
heard with different tastes
different visions so if in independent
filmmaking you try to get your
team to make the same movie in a studio
movie you have to get
the executives and your team to make the
same movie which is sometimes twice as
many people
and makes it harder you see thank you
for smoking
also rob lowe's character that's that's
sort of that's what i envision is this
person that you said
giving notes right
you know that one minute in it doesn't
take long for the first meeting
because there are there are certain
buzzwords that executives i guess in
their 20-minute story training get
told that they will use and if someone
uses that early on in conversation you
know like oh we are
you know i'm just curious what they are
no um like one big thing is elevated
genre we want this to be elevated
sure like what does it mean yeah
they want smart genre they want sure
but that doesn't help us with the
development organic
the characters have to be organic it has
to be character driven
it's these words they're all true but
they're cliches
they came out of a good observation so
if someone's
only contribution during a first meeting
is to ask for a character-driven
elevated horror story i know i'm in
trouble because there's not gonna be
much actual help coming from from that
side you know
um so just kind of like these ketchup
like i i hear a lot of millennials use
the words it's so
meta and i don't even know right like
what or is so epic like so those kind of
buzz words because i'm still
trying to wrap my head around like right
i know what the word means but in the
context of like daily life how is that
how is that experience so meta i don't
know
showing my age but you know what i'm
saying yeah
no that's and you know that when you
actually ask what that means and ask
them to define that there is
well you know i'm like no i don't know
what what does that mean
how do you mean organ you know
right right yeah and then you'll also
get an certain certain buzz phrases too
to question like when you go like that
and that i think will be confusing
they will go like oh the audience today
is smarter than that
you're like that you can say that to
every story problem the audience today
is smarter than that that is not an
approach to actually
so when you get a series of those those
things you kind of know that
yeah right i see yeah
because my experience from the outside
is always that everything
looks so easy and they had the greatest
time
and the script was amazing everything
was
incredible and now i judge my experience
actually making stuff
and i'm like oh i'm on the wrong track
here because my script is not amazing
not everybody loves themselves
each other right or themselves
and it's just it's just messy i always
had the feeling that whenever i get to
talk to like a class of
filmmakers or something that i help them
the most by
saying it is a messy process
i don't know what i'm doing i'm scared i
don't have a vision when i get
i have to pretend i have a vision don't
believe that every filmmaker that talks
about it had this vision
beforehand it's messy and scary and
and painful and you're not if you
experience those things
you're not on the wrong track you're on
the right track you know but a lot
a lot of these interviews these pr
interviews for movies
obviously don't allow you it's nonsense
to do that so you watch that stuff and
if anything it'll it'll hurt your career
because you
think it's it's something different so
yeah that's why i'm always like why do
people even ask
questions that they have to know that
i'm not
i can't answer truthfully because my
career would be over
and to say i hated that producer or that
studio is completely incapable
or that writer wrote complete book a
they don't deserve it for me to call
them out like that because they don't
get to do the opposite
to me with me and b no one would hire me
ever again
so don't don't force me to lie on camera
is what i always think in these press
press
interviews yeah yeah it's tough i mean a
lot of those are just like how is it
what you know i love the
the how is it like to work with meryl
streep you know in your ass which is
kind of an insult
because you're not really there to talk
to that person about meryl streep
you're there to talk about to that
process but so many of those junkets are
like that and
i'll be nervous and hyperventilating
beforehand i'll be like you're ner you
know and then and they come
hey you know everything's great and yeah
yeah it is very surface
um and i could see why people wouldn't
want to do those junkets
i can definitely see it you know it is
it's five minutes get your point okay
buy
next yeah you can't build a rapport with
the person
we had a comment on our channel the
other day and it lends to something that
we were just talking about
off camera and just about having certain
people on your production that are
in your camp and you said someone had
given advice to someone you know and
yeah a friend of mine is a female um
director who's very successful in tv
right now which before she did her first
episode she asked some other
huge tv director i forget who that was
if you had to give me one piece of
advice what would that be
and he said make sure you have someone
that is on your team meaning that has
not been hired by production has not
been suggested
by the producers but someone that you
have worked with and trust and that you
bring into the project
which it doesn't seem obvious in the
beginning because you are so
taken by all the great talented people
that production is
throwing at you that you are happily
taking that one that one that one
and in the beginning everything is rosy
anyway the energy
is like everybody's excited there are no
problems but
but i think the pros the process is one
where no matter how great the producers
are that you work with
i always look at them in the beginning
and go like i know we're going to have a
screaming fight at some point doesn't
matter how great they are
it's just it's like you're going through
this war together you're exhausted
and you don't have 100 overlapping
world view and creative views otherwise
you'd be the same person just by virtue
of not being the same person
that friction especially with the money
involved will
at some point lead to the moment where
you find yourself
on set being screamed at by that person
screaming at that person
and having to figure out the next moment
after that so that's always what i'm
in my mind jumping ahead to and go like
do i want to do that with that person
does that person seem
reasonable and human enough that we will
survive that moment and it's not gonna
taint
everything into bitterness and then uh
connected to that is this bring your own
person because
you will find yourself in a situation
where everything is so crazy and there
are conflicts
and you are not completely sure that
it's not you going crazy
especially because if production comes
with all their people
they owe each other loyalty like if you
have a tv show for example
where they've already done 10 episodes
i'm doing the 11th episode
this whole team has me on set for a week
but knows that then the next year of
their employment
depends on being in good graces with the
producers
if there now is a conflict you will not
suddenly have the team stand up for you
which on a on a movie set you would
because you put the team together
you stuck your heads together creatively
to make this happen
and if there's a conflict with the money
side of things
you are anchored in your creative people
that give you the the confidence that
you are pursuing the right thing for the
right reason in tv you don't have that
for example
so what she was saying to even have one
person there
with as she brought her cinematographer
where she said no i want to hire my own
cinematographer
made a world of a difference because she
knew that she had one ally
on set and again it's really hard
and sounds very negative to think of
conflict
in the beginning when everything is just
fireworks and everything is great
but i think that's a smart way to do and
if there is no conflict i have yet to
see that set where there is no conflict
but if that happens to be the case then
great you know
but at least you have some kind of
insurance of having someone who has your
back
and is not beholden to the producers
well there's a honeymoon phase for
everything whether it's a new job
whatever it is so yeah everyone's going
to be on their best behavior
right and then people's preferences and
quirks and everything comes out
later and then yeah are you able to
recover from it and
still be cordial and professional with
each other even after a blow up right
or does that person hold a grudge
and then to have someone in your own
camp i think that's great and also as a
sounding board somewhat not not as like
a full emotional sounding board but
someone to basically you can run
something by like
was that when i gave that was that clear
right and and
i think that's helpful and that context
the greatest thing of course if you can
bring someone on that you've worked with
before
that can give you context of what we did
we did it before like that what they
want now is different but
who can see what you do in a context
with a little bit of background
i think is super helpful that's maybe
luxury to have that you have someone who
is
uh as professional like the functions on
that higher level that the production
would say yes we will hire
your person instead of our person that
is probably hard to achieve but if it
can
be achieved then that is a big plus i
think
what if a filmmaker finds themselves in
a situation where
they can tell their that the production
is running away from them
and they are it feels like their head
spinning and everyone sort of
got their own agenda how do they make it
through
even if they say okay this is not going
to go well but i need to
i'm contractually you know i'm
contractually
obliged to continue this and i'm going
to stay there and and tough it out
how do you kind of keep your sanity i
think that is the answer
what you just said you just you're there
it hasn't happened to me in in
that bad form and i do wonder that
myself because it's so demanding
to be on set even in the best of
circumstances
that if it's a nightmare atmosphere
continually over days and weeks i don't
know how people
how people do it but i guess if you are
getting paid for it then you just
concentrate on that and go like every
day that i'm on set
i'm getting paid and if i was working in
an office environment i would hate it
too but i'd go
to get paid so i'm doing that now and
i'm trying to
not lose my my sanity
and then if that can be achieved at all
i'm always trying to remind myself
how cool it is that i get to do this and
that i get to
see this even with the nightmare how
amazing that i get to see
an oscar-winning actor
be a diva and be hated by everyone but i
get to see it from the first row
like i'm in hollywood how great is that
and you always forget that because
you're so in it and you go oh i hate
this and i don't want to get to set bob
but if you have a little bit of a
distance which in tv is much easier
because it's not your baby that you have
written and nurtured over years and you
now see fall apart
but it's an episode that someone else
wrote and you are just there to kind of
make it
literally through the day and then it's
a little bit easier i think to step back
but again then it helps if you can turn
to someone at the end of the day and can
roll
your eyes with them and you know that
that wasn't a normal day
whereas if you don't have that person
and you start getting the feeling that
you are the one that is off
and that this is a normal condition that
you're working with i think then it can
really kind of eat away
at you sure that's where you just kind
of keep it so wow
great weather today right yeah yeah very
certain i mean
at some point really it's about making
making it through the day and shooting
the stuff
that is on the page keep shooting keep
shooting keep shooting it's really
in the end um the only recipe you just
have to really
let go of plants that you had
and how you imagined this if you get i
think caught in the spiral of
frustration
i have that i'm in a not in a good way a
perfectionist
in that i get very demotivated very
quickly
if i have the feeling we're compromising
quality right and that that and adds up
because i'm if we do it in the in the
first day i'm already in day two
slightly less motivated to achieve
what in my delusional mind i think will
be this great
cultural masterpiece right and and so
then you get
you have to be careful not to get caught
up in the frustration of that because
every day it will be worse because the
first day you compromise the second day
you have to compromise before
because you compromised the first day so
the third day and gets bigger and bigger
and bigger and in the end you get
you could get to the dangerous moment of
i don't care anymore
you know and to to save yourself from
that
i think it's it's good to let go a
little bit in the beginning
and almost ideally see the humor in it
and go like let's see where this goes
but i still have to deliver obviously
the pages that we have to shoot
every day and then we'll see an editing
if we can
save this thing that's probably how that
would go
he basically said he sees his role as
the director
as the person the host of a party
and he has to make sure everybody is
comfortable and likes coming
and then whatever happens happens
there's only so much you can steer
in the moment but it's about whom you
invite
and that you create an atmosphere where
they can work the best and then to just
keep
looking after their well-being which i
felt was genius
it's just like i'm not that person on
set i've seen directors that are
literal cheerleaders like they will make
sure that everybody has
a blast all the time i need someone else
i need an ad who does that or something
because i'm not
i'm in real life not enough of a party
animal to create that kind of
shot set when i'm working much less much
less
and i have to tell actors that in the
beginning that they don't think my
german
demeanor is i'm miserable right now but
that's just what i look like when i'm
working it's not the
continuous well of joy
which is okay though with i think it's
okay with the people that i work with
one-on-one creatively because we have
kind of i think they appreciate the
the down-to-earthness much more rather
than the party party thing
right but for the overall atmosphere on
set of course that is then
not in my purview so much whether people
and i couldn't tell you after the shoot
if people
behind the scenes had a great time i
don't know because i was so focused on
my thing
and in the end i think from the outside
it always looks as if the director
has to deal with 500 people because the
teams are so big but
really it doesn't make a difference if
i'm shooting a little
student film where i only have my
scimitar my roommate is the
cinematographer and
i have two actors is the same as if
there are 500 other people around i'm
still just working with the
cinematographer
and with the actors i'm not dealing with
the catering people i'm not taking with
the gaffer who has to bring a light from
where
from the outside it looks like this huge
machine that you suddenly have to
control
but in the end it's about three or four
people in a room
doing their thing right so that
atmosphere to me is very very very
important
but whether the gaffer is going out with
the catering
person or not i don't know i can't
control and i don't really care about
you know
so that's that's where my party ends my
party are
these couple of people the actors the
cinematographer the operator
maybe one of the producers if the
writers on set the writer but we are we
would
fit into this room easily and then
there's a party out there
that that i can't control and i think
people figure that out very quickly that
i'm not the
you know kind of party party host
um and i think it's okay with everyone
hopefully i remember
one gentleman addressed the crowd before
something
that we were all gonna work and you just
said look i'm french if i ask you to do
something in the moment
it'll sound really bad but i'm not mad
at you and it was funny and we all
we all relaxed and yeah i was actually a
super nice guy and
but the the fact that he kind of like
made light of it right made you feel
like safe with him wow i've got to do
that for now
jesus it was great that's very good yeah
you know yeah
when you sign on to direct a tv show how
much prep time are you given
contractually i think they have to give
me the script 24 hours
before shooting starts so that's not a
lot
really and it has to do with that
with the fact that i am not expected to
have creative input
into development and into the script at
all i'm being hired to direct what's
on the page i would say in in
real terms how that plays out i usually
have about a week
i would say and that's when i because
i'm coming from the screenwriting
background so i have opinions on the
script for better or for worse and
whether i'm right or not it's a
different thing
but i have the feeling i'm kind of
failing this
this episode if i'm not voicing my
suggestions
which i'll just write up
sent to the showrunner and whatever of
that they want to incorporate
great whatever they don't want to
incorporate great to i that's
the only time i ever suggest that in the
writing stage because then i have the
feeling i've done my work i've
contributed
my filter as the audience reading it
fresh
basically which i think is important for
them to know
because they hired me as a director so
to hear about my
filter and my feelings and my maybe red
flags where i feel like
this or that will be hard to bring out
the way that i think they want it i'd
say that once
um and whatever they reject i know that
they've already worked on it so long and
so many people
had to give their okay to green light it
that i can't come in and change
everything that that
ship has sailed you know and that was
something that took some getting used to
doing tv at first um
and then i go in the time that i have
depending on how much time i
have to sit with it i'm going through
every single scene and i have this
kind of questionnaire of 36 questions
that i asked myself for every scene so
that beca because when i first did i
didn't have it written down it was kind
of a
whatever question i could think of that
i would
would consider with the scene i did and
so much time
was wasted on remembering the questions
that at some point i was like if i just
and i'd like a simplified one for tv
with i think 17 questions or something
and now i'm just gonna tick them off
answer them and to me the great thing is
that with
some questions if you force yourself
to answer like there would be something
like in in what way does the lighting
inform the mood and the scene who's
whose scene is it through whose eyes do
we see
things what is the one takeaway that the
audience has to understand in terms of
information
what is the one visual image that i want
them to carry away blah blah blah all
those things
and some some questions don't seem to
apply at all
at first and if you force yourself to
still think of an answer
they are always the most fruitful ones
because you suddenly realize oh it
applies
big time like one one question would be
for example if you run
completely out of time how do you cover
the scene in the shortest amount of time
and just knowing that that i have that
in my back pocket
gives me a lot of security on set
because i know if
all our there's this saying it's
i'll butcher that saying as you always
say um it's citizen kane in the morning
and it's the duke of hazards in the
afternoon
or something which is so true like you
come
in the morning you have oh and we'll do
this and this and then at the end of the
day it's just like
somehow get the stuff in camera that we
have that scene so when that kicks in
i want to be prepared for that i don't
hope for that to happen but i want to be
prepared for it
or if you wanted to shoot the entire
scene in one take
how would you do that or which how do
you want to shoot the scene
and if you were forced to do it another
way what would you do and just by
forcing yourself
into oh that would be it would have been
my go-to way of shooting this those are
the images that come to mind
in the very beginning instinctively but
if i force myself
to put a pin in that and come up with an
alternative way for whatever reason
there's the more resistance i have to
that
the more interesting stuff comes out of
the answer to this question
that's all a very long-winded say a way
of saying preparing for that stuff
but i'll do that with the um
with the scenes that seem most important
and then the way i structure it which
has
served me well is that i don't start
preparing scenes
with scene one and then go through but i
start preparing scenes depending
prioritizing them by
which scene needs the most answers in
terms of
physical stuff because i know that as
soon as i come wherever we're shooting
the prop master will and want answers
the production designer wants answers
everybody who has to
make something materialize needs some
time needs some prep time
to do that right so if there's a scene
that has
let's say there is the book of the dead
the magical book of the dead
right it would be i i know that the
second
that prop master comes up to me
the clock is ticking for him or her to
get me the best possible version of this
book of the dead
so every day that i go like oh i haven't
thought about that
give me a day the quality of that book
will be reduced and put that person
under more stress
whereas if i can immediately give them
an answer and go like this is how i
picture that
boom they have more time to work on it i
get the better result
right so in the beginning when i first
was preparing episodes
i was kind of preparing the most
character intensive ones first because
they felt the most important
storytelling was
but that was exactly the wrong way to go
because the character stuff
is stuff that doesn't have physical
component to it that has to materialize
i can still rehearse with the actors
pretty short notice
they don't need to know a week in
advance that i'm looking for a certain
character moment
that is pretty it seems important in the
story but in the physical
nature of the overall thing it's not and
then i just
write knowing that other people need
time to think about stuff too i write
down the questions
that i want to answer that i want to
ask certain departments and that i want
to ask
first of all the showrunner because i
don't want to work for a week
and then i have the meeting with a
showrunner and i realize that they have
a completely different
approach to or different look or
whatever whatever so i need my
basic com basic answers to know
what our playing field is to realize
this episode
of course i've watched the ideally all
the episodes that are leading up to my
episode so that i understand
the language of the show and the look of
the show um
and all that i the the one case where i
wasn't able to do it was
my fear the walking dead episode where i
had it was very short notice
and i had watched the first season but
then didn't
watch all the episodes leading up to
mine but i was like i'll get away with
it they will the actors won't know
and they immediately knew like there was
a one or two conversations and they
immediately know you haven't watched the
last because you are asking me to do
stuff
that i have done last episode and yeah
so i'll never
pretend again i'll just say i'm sorry i
didn't watch the last episode so but if
i can obviously watch
the whole build up to it which in
reality
obviously you only get so far until you
hit episodes that haven't
that are not out yet so when you try to
get the scripts for those episodes read
the script
you try if you can get the rough cut
which sometimes already
exists off the episode before yours like
the more
information you can get about the lead
up into your show
i think the better and then i always try
to meet
every actor one on one
because you have so little time to build
a rapport with actors in tv
that even if you have 10 minutes with
them by yourself
they are forced to form a relationship
with you whereas if you do that
with three people in the room sometimes
the producer wants to be there and i'm
always saying
don't don't take this personally but i'd
rather do it
on my own yeah because a group dynamic
is something that will happen quickly
enough but on set you do
need the relationship with each actor on
a private level as much as possible that
was a very long answer
but what if you only have 24 hours
to prepare all of that
prep work watching episodes reading
scripts all of that stuff sounds
wonderful
but if you're giving it 24 hours in
advance
that's got to be really scary because
now you've got to choose
what's most important that i do right
i've never
had it in real life luckily that i had
only 24 hours but that is the dga
mandated minimum
i think my my shortest was uh one week
i mean you then cut corners you watch on
on youtube you watch the recap for the
episodes the two minutes
saying what happened now you read the
wikipedia episode
entries that tell you what happened and
so that you at least have
the story arc down you watch the pilot
for sure
you maybe watch if there is any behind
the scenes footage where the producers
are talking that's worth watching on
youtube because you get a feel for
what kind of people they are and then
going through the script
you would probably reduce your your
character stuff
to what does the character want
in this scene where are they starting
out where are they ending up what's
their want
um because it feels like that is the
minimum of what you need to know going
into a scene working with an actor
that their their want and that every
person in the scene has an objective
what is that
and if you have that then you can
probably walk in especially with tv
where everybody
has played their characters for a while
and knows their character better than
you do
you're probably okay walking into that
um
yeah in terms of the the physical stuff
it's
it is probably worth trying to
communicate
with the departments
already and don't wait until the
producers introduce you
to the prop master because that might be
days and days and days later
but try to be like proactively write an
email to the production so can i have
the email address of the
costume designer of the prop master
email them directly
and tell them what you want you know
start conversation with them
because every minute counts in the end
everything is so stressful
that if you can get a head start by a
day or two
it makes everything much much easier
much more doable
36 questions that you have do you
literally
have them typed out yeah that's great
i've done less and less
now i would say maybe i'm doing 20 now
or something
because you just get it takes a while
like for a movie i would still do that
if i know i have one year before i'm
shooting
i would still do 36 questions for and i
would storyboard every scene
because i always have the feeling if
that the main goal of this whole
of the questionnaire is to force
yourself
to spend 10 minutes inside of that scene
whichever way just be there with the
scene
think of nothing else other than this
scene so that when you do it on set
it feels like territory that you've
stood in once before
that's not the first time i'm now
thinking about it but it's like
and that's why i'm storyboarding stuff i
can't storyboard at all looks terrible
no one can decipher my storyboards
doesn't matter that's not what it's
about and i'm not going to shoot the
storyboards
it's just a method to force myself to
intensely think about this scene for a
second
and you always come up with something
it's not that
i think nick cave said that that about
his muse and whatever he said that
the only job that he has is to show up
at nine o'clock in the morning and
sit at the piano and don't leave until
four o'clock in the afternoon that's the
only pressure he feels
that's his entire job and whatever
happens at that time happens
and with this preparation process i have
that feeling if
at first you go like oh i'm not going to
come up with anything and every scene
looks banal it's two people walking down
the street
there is no subtext what am i even doing
here but two minutes later
just sitting there you go like oh my god
this is a metaphor for
his walk to the gallows and if i shoot
it from here yeah just through sheer i
guess
boredom or something to sit with it you
always come up with something
interesting
and in tv or everywhere maybe i always
have the feeling
if i find one thing
that interests me about the scene one
thing that
where i get up in the morning and go
like oh today i want to do that i'm
looking forward to that
i have to find that in the scene where
they are walking down the street
somehow and you always find it you know
and that
one interesting thing always also
most of the time informs the one
direction that you give your team
because the last thing that a team wants
obviously is for you to do a big
speech 15 minutes long in the morning
about how you see the scene how the
scene
reminds you of your mother if
but if you can give one direction
where it's like let us treat this letter
that the character has put on the table
as if it's
nuclear waste that's how i want it shot
that's how i want every everybo
it's the as if thing it's it actually
said that to me once i asked her what is
she looking for in this
in a direction and she said um
a code word a key basically to open up
whatever that opens up
which to me like changed everything
because it was before because before
that i was that person who would
kind of give these big speeches that i
had thought out before blah blah help no
one because no one can process all that
stuff but since i know that
that unlocking key thing um
that's really what it is because now
everybody can make their decisions
in in connection with this one thing
that i put out there and it changes
everything it changes everybody's
approach to a scene
and suddenly a scene is not generic
anymore because that's the big problem
fincher i think said that it's not
directing is not about
what all you do it's about what you not
do and that's how you define style
which is true it's so intimidating to
think here's a scene
and you could shoot it whichever way
from wherever
which with whatever lens
how do you make decisions and i think
that a lot of directors or beginning
directors get completely lost in that
and go like
i don't know so if you find one thing
that you base it on
it anchors everything and it informs
most of your answers some things it
won't have any effect on
but whether i put the camera here with
the letter in the foreground
or over here without the letter suddenly
there will be an answer to it because
i know that this letter is important and
i want to treat it like a dangerous
nuclear waste artifact so i shoot it
differently so this i think this one as
if thing
i would if i only had 24 hours i would
try to find that for every scene
find the want of each character it would
be a stressful 24 hours to do that but
that would kind of be the minimum
preparation that you probably would want
to do
and when you talked about the fear of
the blank page with screenwriting
it sounds like there's a similar thing
with story parts right
oh see now you are there so there would
be such a thing as director's block
which would be exactly that you can do
anything
so what do you do that's the same as the
blank page
i'm i've just invented this story the
spare time story
because i can't tell bear time stories
if you said tell me a story
there's a prince i don't know yeah and i
just talked to a friend yesterday
and he said what he does is he is asking
their child for three words
and then he will tell a story so if the
child says toilet bowl
tiger and bracelet then he suddenly out
of
infinite options of what to tell has
zeroed in on three things that he will
now connect to something
and make work somewhere which to me was
genius which was what
i was trying to do with that book and
much more complicated he really
distilled it down to something very
simple but i think it's the same it's
the same
with finding that one the approach um to
the scene and there's all
this language around it that is so
intimidating and scary where people
are like oh i want to hear your vision
the production designer goes
what's what's your vision for this and
secretly going i don't have a vision
but you can't say i don't have a vision
but i think that's important not to be
intimidated by but they just
want that one word the key to
how are they supposed to approach
this thing and if you just give them one
that it's like this place has to feel
really lived in
or he hasn't tied it up in two weeks
it opens a whole different door for them
in their department
you know or you want if you talk to the
cinematographer you really want to feel
the presence of his dead parents
by the shadows on the wall but into the
cinematographer it
immediately means aha so we have to we
need light sources that are low so that
the
shadows are being thrown up on the wall
so now the cinematographer has to talk
to production design
to get those lamps and motivate those
it's a whole chain of events
but you have now given them the
direction that
they can work inside of their department
and with other departments
without your constant input and then you
just have to you have to trust
that you're working with good people
that know what they are doing where you
don't have to micromanage where exactly
that lamp
has to stand but you know what the
effect is that you're going from and the
effect you're going for
is and that goes full circle to what we
talked about earlier they are going back
to what do you want the audience to
experience
you know it helps if you know do you
want the audience to feel
comfortable in the space of the
protagonist or do you
want it to feel spooky or do you want it
to feel sterile or deep
because it means something else for
every department but once you figure out
that one word
comfortable or sterile or blah blah
everybody knows what to do with that but
before you give them that one
code word they don't know which
direction to work into with tv it's a
little bit different again because that
world has already been established
and they already know the vocabulary of
the world and they kind of already
know those answers but if you are doing
a movie
where that world only has to be you know
created that's
where that is vital i know from just
doing background work like 15 years ago
that some sets
moved very fast like i can remember
being on er
and i mean the way i mean i was like
i'm supposed to walk and do my craw i
could i couldn't keep up whereas other
sets were slower it seemed like er was
almost like this circular
motion that they had everybody kind of
moved they moved the camera in and
they're going around this one room where
everyone's in these
hospital beds and you're either an
orderly or whatever and the the pace of
that set
was incredibly fast and everybody knew
their role and they had pretty much
designated regular extras and i was just
like a fill-in
and i didn't know how which way was
which where's other ones
it was had been established just
very recently and you know you're
sitting in a church pew
crying or whatever and it was just a
slower thing right so it's just
interesting how certain sets and the
dynamic of
the scene or the sets or the show is
just a faster pace right well that i
think has to do with has that set been
established if they shot 500 episodes in
there
they don't have to figure out how to
shoot that set every time anew but
there's like
you know a kind of process whereas if
it's a church that we have
we're shooting in for the first time you
do have to figure out these
all these things which lens does that
way of the church look the best boba
fett it's all
trial and error whereas with the set
that you've shot on again and again
the trial and error phase is over and
you're just going to go right to the to
the effect
right with the actors and pulling them
aside i find that very interesting
because you're right that people
behave differently with other people
around and then
was that something that you've heard
other directors do that they they like
to
speak to the actor one-on-one without
the handlers or whatever around because
people will receive your message
differently and they'll behave i haven't
talked to other directors about it but i
know that
some productions ask me do you want to
meet them before so and so i know that
it must be a known thing out there that
some directors want to do that
um and i'm sure that every director uses
that time
differently because i in the beginning
was like oh i'm going to go through the
script with them and we're going to
analyze blah
by now it's mostly we're talking about
their pets or my
pets or whatever you know it's really
not even about that we that we sit over
the material together but
really just about that we spend one
moment together
where neither of us are pretending and
playing for a bigger audience but it's
really just
us in a moment but you always go back to
that
initial connection um that that you have
i think that's like the best spent
20 minutes of an entire shoot is kind of
that
alone time and no matter what you do
that's great yeah playing for an
audience that's really that's really
interesting
yeah i think it works the same in
interviews as well when there's less
people around right you get a much
different vibe than
if you do a junket and people don't see
that there's 10
people in the room and it is a different
feeling yeah
are there common traits that a poor
protagonist has to have
a humanity that makes us care about them
i thought that was very succinctly said
i like that problem
that's the only thing i can think of
yeah we had touched on this a little bit
earlier but yeah it's sort of that
moment where you feel like
even if you find out negative things
about them
halfway through the movie that they've
established something that's
given them a likability and that we can
relate to yeah we just want to care
whether someone lives or dies i think
it's
as it sounds like a very low bar but i
think it's actually really hard
to achieve with with our protagonists
to make the audience care whether they
live or die give them an actual
reason that can be verbalized and that
that
works so it's much easier thinking
comedy
or or a dramatic no i think it's the
same there
i think it's the same there pro maybe in
drama even
more because you have nothing to
distract the audience with and with
horror
in the worst case scenario you have
horror pieces that you can distract the
audience with and even if they
don't care about the protagonist they
still come out and go like can talk
about horror pieces with comedy maybe
the joke's still in
what's drama obviously you're dead in
the water if no one cares what your
protagonist but i would
say that in broad brushstrokes that's
the case with all
genres right what do you think
decade uh appeals to you most for
filmmaking whether whatever genre it is
i'm a child of the 90s i can't help it
okay
i have no outside view on
how high quality that was i think people
that know a lot more
about film than me would definitely not
pick the 90s as their favorite episodes
er favorite era but i would say i grew
up with the
with the films of the 80s and the 90s
and they
they are still the ones that that spark
that initial
joyful child in me like
and it doesn't matter if it's obviously
if the films work i think the greatest
time i've ever had in the movie theater
was during indiana jones and the last
crusade
i don't know if that was a great movie
or not but i know that if i had to pick
one the moment of my movie going
experience that i would want to snapshot
and go like that's
what why it's an undescribable joy
to to watch movies to make movies out of
it it would be indiana jones of the last
crusade
so yeah the 80s and the 90s i guess
well something about that theater
experience as a kid is really magical
you know because yeah you're there with
your friends you're eating
st away from your parents you're eating
stuff that you're not supposed to eat
and it was just
like a fun fun movie and you're not yet
intellectualizing it and going like is
it cool to laugh about that joke
is it there was no cynicism to it there
was just a pure
you know a story experience and loving
every second
of it i don't know was this here in the
states
no that was when i was 12. whenever that
came out in germany yeah
and did a lot of american films make it
to the yeah
the hollywood was like the main it was
actually very the
german film was very out of vogue i
can't remember i think
i can't remember during my childhood
ever watching a german movie
that wasn't something they were kind of
they weren't known for the humor or for
their kind of spectacle or anything it
was all hollywood movies dubbed
into german but the same same movies and
some of them were
so well done like star wars to this day
i prefer in german
because it was so well dubbed and the
voices were so distinct and memorable
maybe it's just that i watched it during
my childhood and that's why they're like
in my bones these voices
um forrest gump i thought was much
better in german than anybody
so you know but
american movies all the way through for
sure
someone on twitter had responded to a
tweet that we sent out
and the tweet was a video we did which
is what scripts does hollywood want
most screenwriters are writing the wrong
ones
and so we had a gentleman ask well you
know this is a pivotal issue
do i write what i know and what moves me
or do i write
what producers are looking for so i know
this is a sort of
ever going question
it might also not be as black and white
because what you know
uh and what moves you might not have to
be so
literal you know just because you were
whatever a painter
doesn't mean that you have to write a
script about painting but it could be
any creative obsession right could be
any subtext in that or any
anything that you i think emotionally
know is different from the specifics
of the literal translation of that so if
you can make those two things
overlap for example i'm working on a tv
show right now that has a lot to do with
ambition
um and obviously the protagonist in that
show pushes it to the maximum where i in
real life have never
pushed it but i know what it feels like
to have an ambition where you get to the
point where you say i
i would do anything i would kill i would
die
this has to i have to do this right so
then
i can take that feeling and infuse it
into my character but that doesn't mean
that that character necessarily
literally needs to
wants to achieve the same thing that i
wanted to achieve back then
so i think if there is any way to i
think it's definitely wrong to reject
this notion because i hear that again
and again at film schools when i meet
the
the graduating class or something there
is this vibe of
stick to your guns don't sell out
where i'm always like i'm good luck with
that one
but if there's any way for you to
not stick to your guns and sell out and
still
tell the story that you want to tell
well
that might be the greatest version of it
all because you will not
change hollywood you will not suddenly
your stuff just won't get made
you know and if you want to do the indie
thing great and there might be change
and you might be part of change but
that's a very slow
process so if you instead of rejecting
what producers want and what the
mainstream is and instead of labeling
that as purely negative
but just going can i
give them what they think is going to be
commercial and popular because i want my
movie to be seen by as many people as
possible too
if i don't have to compromise and
sacrifice
the the essence and the dna of the story
that i'm passionate about
then i would try to achieve that
so maybe that's that's an answer to that
i don't think it's either or
you just have to ignore the screaming of
both sides that are making it sound as
if it's
one or the other and just come from your
story side and and see if you can
combine both into into one and make both
worlds work for you and for your story
rather than working against
either of those it reminds me of a quote
i saw
on someone's it was a bumper sticker i
saw i can still remember it was like
many years ago and it is in order to
change the system you have to become
part of the system and i'm sure it's i
i'll look it up and it'll be like oh
so-and-so said that but
that sounds like it's similar for making
movies in some sense
i'm sure there are very a lot of
different ways to go
i just know that the the single focus on
stick to your guns and don't compromise
is not the wisest answer
um and i mean there are definitely
examples probably where people did that
and they changed the world and they
changed film and all that
so i don't want to poo poo on that
either but it's just it's not as easy as
film schools will have it sound as if
it's like the go-to thing of course i'm
an artist and of course i won't
compromise and of course i'll stick to
my guns
if you can work with hollywood if you
are in hollywood and you can work with
hollywood
it might you might go faster than if you
have to work against hollywood
make sense in 2012 when we interviewed
you the first time
you talked about how hollywood is based
on selling promises or i think that's
what we entitled the video
that was a good title too oh okay that's
almost
once you've read the headline you don't
have to watch the video anymore
you thank david for that um do you still
feel this way
very much 100 yeah um yeah
and that those are two different jobs
the directing and doing a good job with
the actual material and
selling in the room what you are
intending to do with the material
that those are two completely different
things
and that the promises um you just have
to if you don't have the confidence
which i'm not that person i'm not the
car salesman
usually you just have to pretend and
just you know
talk about it as if this is how it's
going to be and this is what you're
going to achieve and all your self-doubt
which again you will have in interviews
you always have the feeling that
filmmakers are always clear on what they
want to achieve and how they want to
achieve it and with whom they want to
achieve but everything was great
there's the product that's not how it
really works i think there's a lot of
self-doubt along the way that you kind
of have to get through
but you really i have the feeling for me
at least i have to put that on pause
for the 45 minutes that i'm walking into
that meeting
and just be you know i'm trying to be as
authentic and genuine with everybody as
possible you know
in that room i have to be someone else
for that time
because they don't want the creative
soul
that is you know they want the
manager they want a business leader that
give will bring them the product that
they are paying for
um and that makes hollywood very much
based on promises on pitches and there
are a lot of different names for it but
in the end it's just
you promise a creative outcome that in
the moment you really have no right of
promising
at all um and everybody plays along and
pretends so that's not the case
so what do you say to filmmakers who get
so excited and inadvertently push their
project out before it's ready
and then there it's not perfect
of course it'll never be perfect but
there's maybe
they should have taken more time six
months whatever
but they want to rush it they want to
say i have another film finished or have
my first film finished
i don't know if i have anything to say
to them because it's a it's a
feeling that i've never had i'm the
opposite like i'm
i would sit on it forever if i could
until someone rips it out of my hand and
goes like
good enough and it still doesn't feel
good enough and i still feel like a
fraud somehow with it now
so if they if they have that confidence
that they've made something and they
want it
out the door and they don't have any
second thoughts about it
i would almost say go for it i know the
conventional wisdom from
from film festivals and all is this
don't submit it to us
before it's finished finish but i always
wonder if that's a little bit of a
self-serving
thing because film festivals get flooded
with projects anyway
so it makes sense for them to say don't
send it to us
before you're finished with it but for
you as a filmmaker if you feel okay that
this is
close enough to the best version that it
then it can be
and you are okay with people watching it
i would say
go for it we're just not the responsible
advice to give probably but
i don't i don't know how much better it
really there's always this theory that
now getting the numbers wrong probably
that you have to
put in 80
what is it 20 of the work to get
something to 80
of its potential and the last 20
is where you spend the last 80 of your
work which
is very much my experience and i have
friends that are
totally living in these 80 percent they
just have an idea
they have momentum they do the 20
input have 80 everybody sees the
potential it's great
out the door next project whereas i will
spend the next two years
trying to get the last two that's the
perfectionism thing getting the last 20
right and in the end i would say my
friends
who have done three or four projects by
the time that i've done one
they might have one complete gold nugget
out of their four
projects that might be better than mine
so it's just a different way of
of working um
[Music]
so if someone works like that i would
say go with it because how much
better and it's hard for you to judge
while you're making it but how much
better is it realistically going to be
if you invest
another half a year is that something
that only you because you're so in it
feel but that someone else who hasn't
seen it and watches it for the first
time
it would be an unnoticeable difference
then i would say
good for you for pushing it out the door
sooner i definitely think that
exposing your baby to the world
as soon as possible if you can stomach
it will always
benefit the project rather than sitting
on it too long and having things get too
rigid
and too hard to change i've had that a
couple of times that i showed something
where we were just about to lock the cut
to a friend who had a comment where i
was like i wish i had heard that half a
year ago
that is genius that would have made the
whole movie so much better but now it's
too late because we're about to lock
it was totally my fault for showing that
to people too late because i was too
precious about it
and i should have been more daring and
more courageous
and opening it up to animosity to
criticism earlier
because there was still time to react
then
wow so yeah i guess you can hold on to
something for too long then definitely
interesting forever i mean sure
there are people that are still writing
their first screenplay 40 years later
because it's not good enough not good
enough not good enough which i totally
get
but obviously every film that has ever
been made
had a screenwriter push out his or her
script before it was perfect otherwise
the movie would not exist
right now so i think either way it can
be a problem man
how many screenplays have you been
working on over the last five years
a lot more than i've that have been made
into movies that's for sure
um i would say i've developed or worked
with someone on developing it on
five or six probably more
maybe up up to 10 i would say one we've
developed for
a long time for a studio um
which then took one afternoon for the
new boss that
is a classic story you develop something
with one
executive at the helm who loves the
project and then
they get fired unrelated to the project
the next
generation comes in and goes oh we don't
we don't want that kind of movie and it
doesn't
it's not about the quality of the script
it's about they don't want to make that
movie right now
and then you're pro so there's that's i
think maybe the hidden thing that you
never see about directing that
the majority of work you do on stuff
that never makes it
to the screen and that you never get
paid for and that's just an investment
that you have to make and that hopefully
works out because some of the stuff
does get made which again that's where
the jumping on greenlit projects
comes from because there you have less
of that fallout where you've just worked
needlessly into the void and then
nothing ever comes of it
um but i would say some of the best
scripts that i've ever worked on are the
ones that have not
been made you know and that's what the
whole the blacklist is based on right
it's just a list of the greatest scripts
that have never been made
so someone had to sit on those and
develop those and they probably weren't
paid for it so i'm doing a lot of
that work that you always have to push
away in the back of your head that you
might be doing this in vain right now
because it's so much work and so much
you have to put in the same amount of
emotion
and and put importance on it as if as
you do on the ones that are then getting
made because you don't know which other
ones that are getting made and which
ones are
the ones that are not getting made so it
can be heartbreaking
but that's part of the job i think how
many different screenwriters are you
working with
i i have one david burke who is a genius
screenwriter that i've done
a couple of scripts with and he rewrote
last exorcism he
wrote 13 sins he's amazing so i'll work
with him whenever i can but a lot of
times
the scripts come with other writers
attached and then if producers
are championing the the script i will
work with that writer who
wrote the initial draft so i would say
these 10 scripts over the last couple of
years maybe had
five different writers six different
writers
what's the most challenging part of
finishing a screenplay for you
probably finishing that screenplay
because
there are still so many in my case there
are still so many things
that need fixing um but if
if we waited for me to fix all the
things that i think need fixing it would
never see the light of day
so it's always been the case which i
guess is a good problem to have
that producers are going this is great
this is ready let's do it or let's not
do it or whatever the next step is let's
finish developing it
and i have to get myself to the point
where i'm like okay i'm willing to let
go if it were the other way around it'd
be
trickier i guess if i'm like this is
good enough and the producers are no
it's not
i don't want to be in those shoes either
but my experience is more
the opposite that that other people are
ready to make something much
quicker than i am so that's kind of a
difficult situation to be in
is it the ending of the screenplay or is
it the character arc
what um it's it's it's throughout
because they're in a script there are
obviously moments that work better in
moments that work
less well but oftentimes you kind of
leave the
moment that's a little bit wonky in
there just to be just to not lose
momentum and you
carry on because i think the writing
process
is less like people imagine it where
it's like you write the first act and
then you write the second act and by the
time that you have
reached the third act you're done with
the script but you rewrite
everything all the time and the first
act is maybe the most worked on because
you already rewrite it as you're writing
the other ones
you know um so i don't it's not
necessarily
at the end or whatever but it's all
these wonky moments
where during the writing process during
the draft you go like yeah we'll get to
that later we'll do it
it'll work for another bubble and then
if you're co-writing with someone which
is
what i'm doing that is where you then
have
slight differences of opinion somehow
what we get away with what we don't get
away with what is believable what's not
believable
in the beginning there's always a lot of
agreement
because we kind of see the broad
brushstrokes exactly the same
but the later it gets the more we are
discussing
details all of a sudden where our views
might be different
you know and that's why i like working
with david so much because once you have
worked with someone you know what that
process
looks like where with other where other
writers are might be at each other's
throats
because you know suddenly every detail
matters so much
so it's definitely in the later stages
where exhaustion kicks in
also nothing for you feels fresh anymore
the jokes
you've heard a million times none of it
seems funny the scares aren't scary
um it's just there's a certain dullness
that sets
in that if someone reads it fresh and
that's why it's so important to then
give it to someone
because the other thing that they bring
in other than having notes on it
is an enthusiasm hopefully that you can
feed off of that you've long lost for
you it's just work and it's
another draft and then you have someone
read it for the first time and go like
this was hilarious and it was
scary but you go like oh i forgot you
know that gives you another
couple of weeks of fuel to kind of carry
on as a whole back and forth
what advice do you have for someone
who's having trouble finishing a
screenplay
i have no advice because that goes back
to thinking that that's the the hardest
part
of the whole thing and that's part of
why i don't write because i would not
have an answer
to it because i don't know it's so
ethereal the whole thing you know either
something presents itself or it doesn't
maybe show it to other people i guess
show it to other people open it up don't
be precious about it
and just try to survive the feedback
somehow
i'm always putting a little paper on my
wall before i show anything to anyone
and go like this is feedback it's
supposed to be depressing
so that i can afterwards read and go
like oh i knew this before because i
forget it when i get the feedback
i'm always thinking i'm so depressed
because it surprised me and i thought
the project was great and i get
bad feedback but then i look at the
paper and oh no that's the process i
knew that before that feedback
you you do feedback to get negative
feedback otherwise it would not be
valuable right you want stuff that
didn't work for people but of course
when that hits you like a wave
so you have to be prepared for that but
i think other than that probably
showing it to other people is the only
way to go
what do you want the audience to think
and feel about something you've created
that it wasn't a waste of their time to
consume it first and foremost
hopefully that they were entertained
hopefully
that they feel it was smart and taking
them
respecting them their intelligence um
that it felt true somehow um
maybe emotionally or just that they that
they see
snippets of what their experience as a
human being in the world
is um and ideally that something
surprised them
but then after they saw it again it felt
true to them
um yeah i think i think to forget
for two hours that they are watching a
movie because hopefully the
acting is authentic enough
and the story is engaging enough that
you can just
escape reality for for two hours
so it doesn't even mean that they have
to love it it just means that
they feel that it was real that they
were actually either an observer in a
scene
sitting across from the protagonist or
just i mean
it helps if they love it i love if they
love it um
totally that's that's the added bonus
but i would i would settle for because
that is such a
high standard already these days that
it's not a waste of your time
because there's so much offered for you
to consume
so to decide on something and afterwards
have the feeling that that was the right
choice that was worthwhile watching
to me is already an extremely high bar
so
i'll settle for clearing that but if
they then want to love it
and recommend it to someone else i'm i'm
over the moon that's great
has your view of directing evolved are
you directing now the way you always
have
or things have changed your your 36
questions that you either have in the
back of your mind or the back of your
pocket
have have been added to maybe in subtle
ways
um i got to the point where
in film school you're always taught you
can't the bad director asks for a result
whereas the good director pushes
the the actor into exploring some blah
blah blah
which might all be true obviously like
it's it's frowned upon to say
can you be angrier to an actress
or an actor which is totally true but
what that did to me at some point was
that it
totally paralyzed me because i was so
aware
of this minefield of what all is good
directing
and what what you're not supposed to do
at blah blah blah
and one actor british actor that i
worked with
said that to me i was i was trying to
come up with basically i wanted him
angrier
but there were all these detours because
i couldn't say the word angry
so it had to be like what if this
morning you
woke up and it was just noisy and and
and you
didn't sleep well what would that do to
them and for an hour and a half we would
try to
at some point he was like do you want me
angrier i was like yeah
i was like tell me you want me angry and
since then i'm trying to be less
afraid of doing things that are being
labeled bad directing
if it just so obviously gets you to the
result
faster so i still have on the back of my
mind how the uh what the optimum
scenario is but especially in tv with
the time constraints
um somehow sometimes you just don't have
the time and the tv is also less frowned
upon to just
i think it's already they appreciate if
you have a clear
vision if you have a clear idea what you
want in that scene
and then you can just express it you
don't have to
lead them there without saying those
things so maybe in that way it has
changed a little bit
what do you enjoy most about your career
that i get to work on stuff
that then brings something into the
world that didn't exist before i think
just the creative
process if i if it would be it's a hard
thought for me that i
could do a job where i don't create
anything and at the end it's just
not that those are not not um valid
careers but if i
worked in a bank i wouldn't see that
result the world wouldn't be
obviously a different play it would
probably be but i wouldn't see how the
world is a different place
now that i've been doing something in it
rather than if i didn't exist
kind of a thing so i really enjoy that
that every minute that i spend
working is an investment in my career
but also an investment in
creating something out of thin air and
breathing life
into it and doing that with other
creative people
of which a lot of them have the same
feel the same kind of rush
doing it that's maybe the greatest part
did you ever have a day job where you
had to just
not really create you're just uh just
like internships
and things and i was or being an
assistant in a casting
office i suck at that stuff that's like
and it's also a lot harder
because it always sounds as if the
higher jobs in the film industry
are the harder ones and the lower you
get the easier it gets the hardest job
that i've ever had
was as a pa because
you can't make mistakes as a director if
i make mistakes
nobody notices on the day maybe nobody
ever notices in the editing room and i
can make up for it
in the editing room most of the time if
i make a mistake as a pa
the crew doesn't have breakfast there's
no hiding it's very clear you've
screwed up so you know and that pressure
like i i sleep much better directing
than i would being a
pa you know so maybe it's a personality
thing
but i would not be good at a day job i
think
what are some common myths about being a
film or television director
that you are the creative
of that you're the creative authority
and
force behind stuff like the the the
myth is that the director is this genius
and the writer somehow is not
or whatever it's very clear that
the hardest thing is to come up with a
great story and the director
is then only the one who finds the best
way of telling that story and
translating it to screen
but the creative genius i don't want to
poo poo on my fellow
fellow directors there are genius
directors out there
but the the writer is the
the one that came up with the spark and
if we're talking about creating
something out of nothing
who literally created something out of
nothing so i would say
95 of the credit should go to the writer
five percent should go to the director
the math is wrong because there should
also be some for the actors and
everybody else
but it is it's weird for me to say see i
don't know how it happened maybe it's
just a personality thing that
directors tend to be more boisterous and
somehow more
i don't know grandstanding or something
but how the directors
became the kings at the alleged kings of
the filmmaking world
rather than the writers i have no idea
so in that case the
the television world reflects that the
reality to me a little bit better even
where the writer clearly is the king
and the director isn't
what about that when the director puts
themselves in the film
how do you feel about that in a
documentary setting or
always a no in a narrative i have no
no strong feelings as long as
the fact that they do that doesn't
compromise the quality of the
film itself like if it's if it takes you
out of the film and i'm like oh that is
so and so then that'd be bad but if
they're a good enough actor that they
can fit in
i understand the thrill of literally
putting because you're putting so much
of yourself
into that stuff anyway but it's
invisible to suddenly
break that wall and enter the world of
your film
literally and physically for a moment i
totally understand why that is
um interesting it has nothing to do with
oh look at me or with an arrogance
or or something i would totally if i
were a better actor and i could just be
for a second to walk you know through
and do something i would totally do that
just out of a
juvenile thrill of you know
yeah so i have nothing nothing against
that at all
like the scene and was it staying alive
that john travolta bumps uh sylvester
stallone
for one minute on the street and you
know hey yo what do you know is this
like this
quick thing but unnecessary death you
you weren't
i was in there for a split second okay
but that was only because
my voice was coming from behind the
camera throughout the film which was
important to me that i could
could change events in the moment by
actually participating in them as the
documentarian
so that then when we needed that
documentarian on screen
they would have needed my voice and my
accent and all that anyway so i was like
then i'll just do it myself
um and it was so short though because
everybody else around me they're such
better actors than i am that we kept it
very very short so that doesn't take you
out of out of the whole thing how has
the popularity of the internet affected
what you do that's an interesting
question i don't know if it has or not
that i'm aware of
at all would would my movies look any
different
if they were made in a pre-internet
era i wouldn't be able to i mean
obviously i couldn't check
twitter afterwards to see how people
felt about certain aspects
but other than that i don't have a
feeling
other than maybe an awareness that
you're competing with even more
uh stuff that's being offered with
youtube and with all those things
um and that that people's patience
because of that
is much shorter than it used to be but i
don't know if in another way it's that
affected by it
do you think uh any of the desires to
tell certain stories
have changed
i mean it's like we used to turn on 60
minutes
back in the day to see an expose on
something and
it was exciting and you'd hear the clock
ticking and all that i mean
now all we have to do is just pick up
the phone for one second
right and look for a notification and to
see
something tragic happen or something
amazing happen or some celebrity has a
an opinion on something and
you know i used to see mike wallace sit
down and like really grill somebody
that's right i think that is maybe why
it's a little bit immune to that
is that long-form spelling storytelling
process which so far hasn't been that
affected
by it the the 90-minute to hour arc
has the the internet has not yet
dismantled
that they have all the short form is
there and the vine
the you know all the snapchat everything
which i think now more companies are
starting to cater to that to
tell their stories in 20 second or two
minute chunks or something for the
internet generation
but so far what i'm doing has been a
little bit immune against that because
it always dealt with the long
form that has not been that influenced
by the internet i think
looking back now on your career
why are you still here in hollywood well
what stories do you still want to tell
why does it still drive you to be here
you talked about ambition
for this one character that you were
thinking of and
and how you were either not like that
character or you were
right i mean the very superficial level
is really that this is one of the only
places in the world where you can make a
living
doing what you love if filmmaking is
doing what you love
but then also it's a very high standard
of professionalism
in the town obviously the cruise you get
here
the creative talent that is here
and you have to have so many meetings to
make like you have to have 100 meetings
with different production companies for
them to
for one project to then actually get off
the ground that i don't know how you
would do that
living anywhere else because you'd have
to fly into los angeles constantly to
kind of
have meetings so at the moment i don't
see any other place in the world that i
could live and be a professional
filmmaker but that might well be
possible i just i have no experience
with it so plus i have a family here now
i like los angeles as a city which i
know is very
unpopular thing to say i really like it
um and i don't know why i would want to
live anywhere else
yeah it's interesting because i look
back on um i told you i was watching
this raymond chandler documentary
and you know he wrote about la as
someone from the uk
and uh romanticized a lot of it i know
he talked about
you know the the crime criminal element
but
um there are many parts of it that
you leave and you're like i missed that
i would miss
having access to so many things right at
my fingertips so yes the traffic is
terrible um and there's it's very
crowded but yeah there's
so much here and it's also very
beautiful
parts of it are incredibly beautiful so
i know sometimes we
focus on what i feel like is too much
negativity on la and you know i've been
guilty of that
but uh there are some really fantastic
things about the city
and you can walk to so much but um back
in germany
watching these films whether it was a
dubbed version of
you know carrie fisher delivering a line
of star wars
did you know you were coming here was
that a plan no
i went to film school just for writing i
came from the dungeons and dragons
field which i was my favorite guest
still is my favorite game
just the rush of being able to create
something out of nothing just because
there's a group of people sitting around
making something up suddenly it exists
for everybody was mesmerizing to me so i
thought how can i do that professionally
writing was the answer so i was looking
for a writing program which happened to
be
the film school in germany and so i did
the whole screenwriting program and
that's kind of where the filmmaking
bug got to me a little bit because it
felt weird that there's another person
marching in
suddenly taking my story and being the
director and whatever when i'm like i've
already got that story in my head why
would i need someone else to tell it to
the
actor the production designer the
cinematographer
and stuff and then i came here for
directing so i was
20 or something when i realized that i
was going to make films
my my teenage self didn't know that yet
if you were to go back and give yourself
advice what would you say to yourself
even if it's just some like very quick
sort of flipping advice
stay away from
a certain producer that completely
destroyed
a movie that i did which had a very
harsh impact
on my career that's not very good advice
for anyone else watching but if i have
to be honest i would have to spot one
thing where i was like but i also
didn't have any influence over
[Music]
over whom the movie was being sold to so
i don't know if i should have pulled out
and looking back now i would probably
pull out before
i make the movie but i didn't know that
then and i can't blame myself for not
knowing that
then but that would be the one piece of
advice that i would give myself
i think anybody who's been in an
industry
long enough has probably had a story or
two like that right and so you don't
know at that time
you have no idea and i also don't want
to blame everything
on record like oh i've been making
blockbusters now if that one
experience hadn't happened but it's
it was a very tangible
moment where things went very
differently from the path that
everything else was kind of
lining up to be but obviously there's no
good in
sitting at home and going like i've been
wronged you know that just happens i've
also had a lot of luck with a lot of
stuff so i guess that's just
how it goes sometimes you win sometimes
you lose
what are the stories you want to tell i
don't know if i have specific
kinds of stories i want to tell i just
want to tell
good surprising smart stories
i think it's almost more about the how
to tell the stories than what what to
tell them stories which goes back to
i don't know if i have one big message
for the world which is why i don't tweet
i have nothing
just to say to the world that the world
needs to know it's the same with a movie
i don't know if i'm
in possession of any truth
that will change the world if i just
can't get the world to hear it and it's
the one
story that keeps me awake at night it's
really just about
trying to make stories that that
really have an impact on you
as a viewer in the moment that to me is
kind of the
my goal to which i'm responsible for my
craft
basically and what what happened in the
bigger
context of of which messages are being
put out in the world i don't think that
i'm a filmmaker
that rises to the level of i
am putting um stuff out into the world
that is of any significance in terms of
political change
social change of that my cosmos is kind
of
smaller and more intimate and is more
the authenticity of
the human experience in the moment
of the of this of the individual in the
moment
and i'm pretty happy in that field